ladies and gentlemen um
i've got here a special lager i'm going
to crack it open
pour one out for our good friend steven
crowder no i'm not really going to pour
it out i don't want to get beer all over
my studio actually drink it
crowder got locked out on on twitter oh
now i spilled it you see what happens
when i try and do a stupid bit
like marco rubio crowder got locked out
like marco rubio was that what he did he
spilled beer
he had the little baby bottle here and
he was very awkward about it
so crowder goes on twitter he has a
segment where he sent
some i guess you can call him
investigative journalists to look into
voter addresses that were in a database
and
turns out there are a bunch of parking
lots he had them hold up a newspaper
from this week and crowder is saying
he can prove this is what crowder is
saying
that many of these addresses in these
databases don't actually exist
that's all he's saying he tweeted that
twitter has locked him out for 12 hours
i'll tell you what's really annoying
i tweeted that he's been suspended i put
in the title of this video he's been
suspended because that's what suspend
means
suspend is temporary but twitter likes
to claim
suspension they use that word because
ban
is so harsh and it's bad press so
they'll suspend you
permanently yeah okay permanent
suspension that's dumb
it's a temporary suspension he'll be
back and we'll you know
he'll probably have a ton to say but
we're gonna we're gonna talk about what
what you know what he found and i'm sure
many of you saw
you know what he was uh you saw his
segment from the morning so i think
there's a lot to talk about in this
regard
and what happened with the supreme court
because clarence thomas
basically dropped a hammer saying it
looks like
you know that there was a good argument
from these republicans in pennsylvania
about mainland voting
we'll get into all that stuff we've got
a bunch of other articles obviously we
always do we'll talk about coca-cola
because linkedin is now panicking after
coca-cola said try to be less white now
linkedin is getting flack for it so
we'll get in all that stuff
we also have something tweeted by
matthew iglesias he's one of the
co-founders of vox.com
he tweeted something about how he wanted
to like like just cause drama
and it's a it's a poll about men and
women and who wants to be working at
home and who wants to be working and so
obviously
no matter what the poll results are he's
trying to light the internet on fire but
i think it's a good subject talk about
it
and we actually have someone here who is
uh uh probably a good person to talk
about a lot of this stuff we got mike
cernovich
thanks for having me do you want to
introduce yourself yeah mike cernovich
just got in town long trip
it's good to see everyone you seem wiped
out no not wiped out at all it's just
whenever it's somebody else's show i
like to let them pace it yeah
because i just don't believe in going in
on someone else's show and be like you
know here we are
we'll do it too yeah you gotta you gotta
find the rhythm with the other person or
else they'll um well
how would you describe yourself for
those that might not be familiar with
you you know at this point i don't even
know man
i just hang out with my kids all the
time now but i'm still sort of an
entity that exists that can get
attention and move the needle on certain
things but
i started off uh you did do primarily
mindfully
a little bit yeah yeah i primarily
started off doing mindset work gorilla
mindset
start off as a lawyer i ran into you the
first time at the
rnc i think you were with fusion and
that was your i think oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah early iteration so
that was where everybody was like don't
talk to that guy that has a fusion
avoid that guy they're woke yeah avoid
that
yeah we got that great video of the
person burning a flag and then somebody
went to kick the flag out and then i
caught got caught in a woman's dress
actually
she had this long flowing dress and then
that was where i just got in the carnage
of the the media political world and
probably you know
at the conventions and i'd done other
little things here and there
and then you know i just kind of like
became a thing plugged along
my friends got all hired in the white
house so then i had all the like the
best stories and sources and everything
yeah then
would break all that stuff and then
you're like i mean i was in your movie
you were working with the you guys were
the best part bilderberg yeah luke
bilderberg so you guys
it's weird because i'm the oldest guy
but you guys are like anxious in terms
of
having been around much longer in this
world because i was like wait that was
luke at bilderberg in
i don't know 2012 or something 2007.
yeah a long yeah yeah a long time ago i
think it's interesting how
you you you gain a lot of prominence as
one of the highest profile trump
supporters
but then you started calling out it's
gonna be interesting as we get into
you know talking about crowder and stuff
you started talking about how like it's
over basically you're like these people
are duping you who are claiming that
there's going to be some magic turn
around
people got mad at you for a lot of trump
supporters were mad but you were right
yeah because i came from you know like a
law background law school
i knew all the federalist society people
i know how elite people kind of think
i was actually chapter president in law
school for my own
so i've done all these little things met
all the right people the white shoe
people
and i'm just like this is not the way
the world works and people get mad
because
one thing trump did that was amazing is
he brought out what they call low
propensity voters but people who don't
actually vote
so this was their first election so they
come in and they want to like tell me
things and i'm like
what you're telling me is wrong
everything you're telling me is wrong
everything from how the supreme court
operates to how the supreme court
because if you talk about the clarence
thomas
descent from denial certiorari the idea
is that supreme court is an institution
that makes political decisions
it isn't just a bunch of judges looking
up the law and making these choices
they're saying well
after january 6th do you want to risk
the legitimacy of the court
to side with trump who right does
anybody really like it
anyway we'll get in all that especially
with the the crowder stuff we also got
luke he's hanging out welcome back
beautiful and amazing human beings this
is okay
if we are change.org i like a high pace
as you can see here
with my conversations and uh i think the
shirt i'm wearing i need to clarify
statistically is correct and it says for
your information the government is way
deadlier than
any virus historically that's true and
if you want to support me and get the
shirt you can on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com thanks so
much for having me i love the
conversations here
what up guys and uh i'm ian crossland
coming at you from the internets uh mike
you mentioned
guerrilla mindset i just wanted to show
this book this is your book
and you wrote this in 2015. and can you
tell me what is this exactly
yeah i mean it did well too it actually
did did a lot it was a
a mindset book for men but it was more
like manual
by manual i mean like a manual versus
hey get
get rah-rah get hyped up get motivated
because
the genre of self-help or
self-development is largely
youtube videos of a guy saying and then
he dragged me into the water and was
gonna drown me and said but you want
success so much that you're gonna drown
then you really want in your heart and i
thought that's just kind of dumb you're
sitting around watching youtube videos
all day
what's an actual specific uh
step-by-step program
that you can take and apply and it's
largely written for introverts
there's a lot of stuff there about
self-talk a lot of their about rewiring
memories in your mind rewiring your
thought processes
so it's about going deep into yourself
on a mindset
level and that one i did in that came
out 2015. where's the best
place um we'll we'll we'll definitely
get to that later so we also have your
patchwork i am here pushing the buttons
i'm going to love this conversation i
can tell already
and before we get started head over to
timcast.com to become a member we've got
a bunch of exclusive members only
podcasts we just did a full
hour with sydney watson the other day
she was here on the show and then we
just
started talking about kangaroos for
whatever reason and then we also have uh
we had just basically three back-to-back
full bonus episodes so go to
teammates.com become a member
you can watch those episodes and it just
helps protect us in the event that we
eventually get nuked because we're gonna
be
we're talking about this a lot i guess
stephen crowder is locked out of twitter
and
you know so sign up and make sure we
don't you know lose it
that being said let's jump to the first
story
i tweeted this stephen crowder has been
suspended from twitter
after saying he can confirm that people
voted at addresses that do
not exist he stated the same in a video
so
you may have seen the video it came up
earlier this morning
he uh did this on his morning show he
literally
sent people to addresses let me see if i
can pull up like a screenshot
trying to find it there we go wait we
just lost it so there we go
is that let me see i'll just play a
little clip from this from his bit so
you can see they're holding up the
newspaper they go and they find these
like
well this is just like it looks like a
house here we go empty parking lots
one of them that was really interesting
was that he hol they're holding up a
newspaper
and they shall empty parking lot and
apparently there was supposed to be an
apartment number 409 now
i'll put it very very simply crowder
claimed all of this
on youtube he's he straight up said that
he can prove it
and he will testify under penalty of
perjury that this is true these
addresses do not exist
i'm simply saying he's saying it i'm
showing you what i saw
it looks compelling i wouldn't need to
actually check the addresses because i
gotta be honest i'm just seeing
crowder's video but
i i don't think he'd go when he'd make
this up the crazy thing is
crowder did not say he actually
clarified this very very clearly
that he's not saying this is evidence of
any you know bigger scheme or anything
like that just that
they found evidence of addresses that
don't exist that's all it is
it doesn't mean the entire election is
bunker anything like that but they
should certainly be looked into right
that's well that's as as far as any
reasonable person would go
until you get to like courts or
adjudication twitter
took down locked his account because he
tweeted this
that to me is absolutely insane because
he actually has
video showing this so he did put up an
article on his uh
on his website and he says proof we went
to fake photo addresses he
he talks quite a bit about it but that's
the gist of the story he is you should
check out his bit too because it was
pretty funny where he kind of talks
about mike lindell having this bad
information
believing his dominion stuff and he's
getting sued over it but he also
mentions that
you know mike lindell has this
documentary called absolute proof
and crowder did the segment called like
absolute proof 100
fair trade definitive and all that stuff
so
i actually i think you know considering
mike you're a lawyer i'm curious uh what
your thoughts are because we
we should we should definitely talk
about the supreme court as well and and
pennsylvania
yeah the so that was another reason that
i clash
so much with the first time trump voters
is they were coming they were saying all
this dominion stuff and i'm like no
that's not how it works
there was no shootout like i'm i'm like
why am i the debunker
my job you mean in germany they claimed
that servers were being airlifted
it's crazy satellites in italy like
someone was telling me that i'm like
huh are you kidding me and i hate doing
that because
trump supporters are so attacked on
every side
the last thing i want to do is shoot
inside the bunker
but i don't want people to believe
things that are wrong and the problem
here
to tie to that point with crowder there
was a guy you guys would know his name i
forget it right now but
he went through and did an analysis like
this of
nursing homes halfway houses other areas
and by the way i'm not making any claims
but it showed like oh wow so there's a
hundred votes came out of here some of
them were supposedly mail drops
and there were a lot of things that you
could look at like crowder looked at
but instead everybody now thinks the
narrative is that
a few goofballs on the internet or in
the case of mike lindell successful
entrepreneur who believes what he said
which as a lawyer makes that a really
interesting case because
usually as you know to suit someone for
defamation you have to show actual
malice
was malice doesn't mean that you didn't
like the person malice means that you
didn't actually believe what you were
saying
or you entertained doubts about what you
were saying like that mike lindell knew
what he was saying was false yeah or
dude believes at all yeah he believes
he's like hell yeah you're suing me this
is amazing i can't wait to see you guys
in court
so as a lawyer thinking that this is
actually uh a newer area of law like how
do you actually get him for defamation
but
the problem is that became the whole
narrative of it where now
mark elias and other people say oh the
trump people filed 100 lawsuits none of
them went anywhere this is proof there
was nothing there and it's like no
they they found like a couple one of
them was the pennsylvania one that
didn't get heard
and when you look at the issues that
they tried to resolve
they were quite interesting or if you
look at the evidence that was presented
that crowder is presenting it's quite
interesting it's the kind of thing that
makes you a hmm
maybe you should think about but that's
been completely hidden in the squid ink
of this dominion stuff and all the weird
conspiracy i'm rarely call some of the
conspiracy theory but there's no other
word for that if i if i had to have a
conspiracy
it would be that the conspiracies are
the conspiracy to derail the actual
conspiracy
you see you see what i did there no i
believe that no i i i
i'm not saying it's true i'm just joking
no but i actually vacillate between
because there are some people that are
so they lead people down such a bad path
that you think in life you get lucky
you're going to have some wins and
you're just a loss after loss after loss
so i'm a little co-intel pro conspiracy
orientated where i do think a lot of
people do
set you up well you don't need to have a
conspiracy here we have
cass sunstein obama's information czar
that literally wrote the playbook on
disinformation and he talked about
creating fake
conspiracies to make anyone questioning
government look insane
and he did this specifically with a lot
of family members and rescue workers in
new york city
after the 2001 events so that you know
he he wrote it in his own
bylands in his own published paper i
asked him about it he denied even
writing it even though it's it's still
up there on the internet
uh it was published in one of um
scientific journals that he wrote about
how to combat and fight this
information and one of his ways was
infiltrating groups in real life and
online and making them look crazy and
that's and that's what i kept
complaining about when these people come
out with these really absurd
conspiracies about like
cia agents storming german servers and
then like italy and whatever i'm like
who cares
who cares we've got a constitutional uh
legal battle happening in pennsylvania
that's more important and could have a
bigger result
well then you had you had credible
testimony under oath in the michigan
hearings i actually watched the hearings
and my jaws were dropping you had
credible normal decent people
providing eyewitness testimony of what
they saw but nobody watched the hearings
the pennsylvania hearing that didn't
really get covered the michigan one
which i found quite persuasive
wasn't really covered so now when people
think of
you know i don't want fraud of the
election
then that's what they think is all this
really kooky stuff when actually there
were issues there were issues with
people changing the rules midstream
which is what happened in pennsylvania
where as you aptly tweeted if they
change the rules and you sue they go
well you know i'm standing nothing bad
has happened
and then the rules are applied and then
you see when they go well it's too late
now it's moved
right it's like i said that's 22. yeah
that's that's a horrifying precedent and
that's basically what we got with you
know clarence thomas and
claire's thomas in his descent he said
we did we failed to
you know rule on this before and now
we're not going to after
what are the rules like no one's going
to know no one's going to have any
confidence in the system
right and that was a legitimate legal
issue that was a legitimate case
that should have been heard but the
supreme court justices
i think kavanaugh and bear i think they
would have heard it
had january 6th not happened and
moreover had there not been all of these
the linwood stuff and all this other
things that people brought up is
you don't want to be caught up in that
net of here's all the kooks and the
kooks are in the net
and now you're a supreme court justice
and you're in you're in the net with
them
you're i hear you but man talk about
cowards
i i wouldn't care i don't care okay well
i'll make the case for them then i'll
make the case for john roberts as an
institutionalist
the way that john roberts would say it
if you're being candid is that
the this is how you learn it in federal
courts and law school and
is the supreme court is a co-equal
branch of government just like the
congress interests like the executive
branch
they had to fight and scrape for all
their legitimacy and all their power
the supreme court was not powerful at
all actually before the war in court
in the 1950s so what do they have they
don't have
guns they don't have a budget they don't
have any real power all their power is
soft power
right so if you're going to enter an
area that
where there's such a narrative that's
already set so strongly
as there is now with this election stuff
then you're attacking or you're going to
make the institution weaker by doing it
now you would come back and say why you
don't agree with that and i would
agree with you but that would be what
john roberts would argue so when people
talk about john roberts
a lot of um conservatives people
especially he's an institutionalist so
fundamentally his
even comey was the same way comey is it
was
way was crooked so it's maybe not the
right example but
the idea is you protect the institution
the institutional supreme court that
means you have to pick your battles
and if you're going through the calculus
you're thinking yeah you know do we
really want get involved in all this
stuff when there's
talk of insurrection it could be that
they it's a fight they knew they were
going to win anyway so they said it was
moot
yeah exactly and and some people call it
a cop-out which is a fair point
other people will say that you have to
protect the soft power of the supreme
court
and there's a fair point that because a
lot of our institutions have lost
soft power when you say that that he
would fear that it's going to weaken the
institution
is that it will weaken the perception of
the institution through the media
well yeah through the collective hive
mind so the idea is that
the supreme court can't cut anyone's
budget but
congress if they wanted to could cut the
law clerk budget there's all these
different ways that they could they can
mess with them
the supreme court if they want to have
an order enforced they can't have the
fbi
kick down the door and take power their
rule is by reason
their rule is by soft power their rule
is by people saying
that's the supreme court opinion that
really means something
after bush versus gore you got to
remember if we hadn't had 911
bush versus gore would have been four
years of bush being the orange man
the the institution of the court the
soft power of the court had declined
significantly because it was a
close opinion on partisan lines and it
was a little dodgy even by
by my assessment of it so you had a loss
of institutional power
a loss of saw power the idea that this
is a supreme court this is an edict
you should follow it because ultimately
if the supreme court issues a ruling
that
an executive officer doesn't like the
president could just say well i don't
know who cares
right there was a believe was andrew
jackson who said the supreme court has
issued their ruling
not let them enforce it that all that
historical background is swirling around
and it is fundamentally true if the
supreme court issued a ruling and trump
didn't want to follow it he could just
say
we're just not going to abide by this
rule what are you going to do
i have my praetorian guard so there
there's a lot of conflict there and
soft power is kind of an amorphous term
too which is how do people rule
well the supreme court they don't have
any hard power congress has hard power
right
they can like what subpoena power uh
well by hard power i mean they can
actually do things to you like
you don't have a budget the lights
aren't gonna work they can pass laws
making something a crime
right they have an enforcement mechanism
whereas like even the media
to put a different example the media has
no hard power soft power
as more people just say we don't really
care as elon musk
tells the washington post i don't care
i'm not going to answer your articles
and as more people say we like elon we
don't like the media who cares
the media doesn't have any power anymore
right the power is only in that
ability to shape public opinion the
ability that
oh this isn't the new york times this
must be matter this must be true this is
how we're gonna live our lives
so that's the supreme court even though
it's a branch of government
elon's response was pretty telling today
because the washington post
quoted him as saying quote give my
regards to your puppet masters
when they asked him for an interview so
he didn't just like
shun them away he made sure to send them
a message
especially to the washington post which
is being seen more of an institutional
establishment kind of
paper of record for the intelligence
agencies i won't i won't do interviews
with any of these people i won't i
ignore them and honestly
even in like smaller independent and you
know whatever you know channels i
i won't do that for the most part either
there's very very few anything i'll do
with
anyone else the whole system is is just
man is a clown show to put it mildly
right and their soft powers decline so
here's what i mean by that
is it used to be that a hit piece would
actually kind of damage you
right you got hit you got written about
it said bad things people say oh i don't
know if i want to talk to that person to
be around that person
and then it it changed the point where i
don't even respond
only kind of boomers like jordan
peterson responded hit pieces oh read
this mean thing they said about me
everybody else knows your people aren't
even going to read it 99 of them aren't
even going to read it first of all
the ones who do read it aren't even
going to believe it so even if the media
writes something about you critical
that's true
your own follower is going to say oh
they probably just made the whole thing
up the whole thing's
fake that that's a change though and
that's what i mean by the soft power the
ability to shape
narrative the ability to shape public
perception i i got to be honest
if that's i heard you're saying and i
understand it and that sounds to me like
the supreme court is
a bunch of cowards they're weak they're
pathetic they have no real power anyway
and it sounds like you've got these
three branches of government where they
pretend the supreme court is co-equal
when in reality they're like the loser
kids in the in the corner of the
playground
and they're only their only claim to
power is like that little kid in recess
who would suck up to the teacher
is just crossing their fingers and
hoping you listen to them if they're not
actually going to stand up for anything
then what's the point of having in the
first place
well they would say that they're just a
check on government that checks should
be
used in exceptional circumstances and
under limited circumstances that was the
idea
that's why when people talk about
judicial activism they're talking about
the court taking a very active role as
the warren curd
oh there's a right to this there's a
right to this there's a right to that
there's a right to that
these rights are protected the other
rule or rather the other view of the
court is a more conservative one
jewish potentially not necessarily
politically which is that the supreme
court shouldn't get involved in this
kind of stuff so i'll give
you a great example is if donald if the
senate had
um convicted trump and trump had tried
to sue in the supreme court there's
something called the political question
doctrine
which holds that they would just say
this isn't for us to decide this is a
political question so there's things
called abstention doctrines
and one of which is a little bit
different from standing but the idea of
abstention is
even when the supreme court has
jurisdiction they won't
hear the case under these various
doctrines so you're right in the sense
that they're
not the most powerful but somebody like
john roberts would would maybe cheekily
respond
i agree with you that's the point where
we are the little kids we're not the one
who's supposed to oh that's
that's that if if that were the case and
it sounds like it is
then that's means serious trouble for
this country
it means there's no resolution to make
to serious disputes it means that the
conflict that has been escalating over
the past several years will have
no resolution your hope is that this
this council of
legal experts and elders can step in and
say
we've heard the arguments and we will
now be the tiebreaker the referee in
this one
instead they said you've complained
you've actually brought up some
interesting arguments
shove it yeah i mean look look at the
way andrew cuomo treated the supreme
court they
told him they ruled his lockdown orders
were unconstitutional he said
i don't care i'm just going to do new
ones that don't apply to this specific
one
so you know seeing andrew como do this
really kind of
signals that the supreme court is not
going to be your savior like many people
can we i see like the supreme court is
like a lens that's focusing
the law for the american people to see
clearly and it's up to us as the people
to enforce what they can kind of show us
but
that's all they really do is pass
through ideas it's meaningless
well i i would say this though is if as
critical as i might be the supreme court
or federal judges especially in federal
courts
i would trust the federal judge if i had
to choose some kind of like gambit
do you trust this random member of
congress with your rights you trust the
president with your rights
trump or biden or do you trust a federal
judge with your rights i would trust the
federal judge
i think you'd be better off choosing a
partisan member of your tribe in a
political party
yeah but we're doing a rawlsy and veil
ignorance thing though we're saying that
you can't get to pick like
i would obviously you know choose if you
could choose the referee you can't but
if you're looking at just in terms of
the system i would still say the courts
are
better equipped and more likely to to
vindicate or care about individual
rights
and the flip side too is the january 6th
i mean if you're an adult and you watch
that you say that's a bad thing
you know but 9 11 9 11
right we live in a childish world where
every adult is going to be like yeah
this is bad you know you need to suss
out who is
doing what but we have to we're supposed
to basically pretend
which i say we off we live in like the
age of pretend which is oh my that was a
9 11.
holy cow event so it's this fake emotion
and the supreme court
they're sensitive to that the idea that
it's 9 11 but in a way it's worse than 9
11 because
the 9 11 terrorists all got pro bono
legal representation by the most elite
lawyers in the country
none of those elite lawyers are going to
do anything for these trump supporters
outside of that uh people who have been
detained in guantanamo bay
will get these very high prestigious pro
you know pro bono
are you donating uh donating their time
but you get you get
you know uh bernie bernice
from oklahoma who's being charged with
two misdemeanors for trespass
and a lot of them are and the lawyer's
like i'm not going anywhere near that
and what's worse about that is they're
being held
this is the thing where if you're a
lawyer you're like screaming on the
inside because
and federal court's a little different
than state there's something called the
federal sentencing guidelines
it's very like mathematical is it your
first offense was it a non-violent
offense what did you actually do when
you get your like time
most of the indictments i've read are
bernice
some mag of grandma you know read some
weird thing on the internet
showed up didn't know there was a riot
because she's just following the crowd
walks in oh hi everybody and she's just
smiling and thinks nothing happened
well that's trespass that's a day in
jail maybe
but they're being held without bail
right so they're doing they're actually
going to do more time pre-trial it's
supposed to be the opposite because
you're presumed innocent this is the
scary thing about what we're seeing
right so
there's some other stories we can maybe
get into a little bit like the fbi
seizing congressional phone records
saying that members of congress are now
suspects you've got naomi wolf she
originally won tucker carlson saying
talitarian totalitarianism is here and
and we'll jump into those and
get into those in in fuller detail in
just a second but what's scary is
that the democrats will not stop they
won't the republicans
are worthless republican leadership is
an oxymoron and they're basically just
like
you know democrats do your thing the
democrats are basically saying we will
use the most
insane interpretation of anything that
we saw we will use
every bit of power we have and the
republicans would never do that
they're too weak so the democrats are
going to start steamrolling people
people who who there's some video where
the cops opened the door to the capitol
and people just walked in confused
confused and bewildered those people are
now facing serious jail time
then you have the year of riots where
people literally burn down buildings
what did merrick garland say well
well it's extremism because it happened
at night but it's terror because it was
during the day or something like that
i i understand going out there going
after like the electoral college vote
count
is very very serious but don't you think
burning down buildings and destroying
cities and what the 19 plus dead
directly from the riots as well as the
chas
where they pumped for 10 minutes
hundreds of rounds into an suv with two
teenagers in it
these people shouldn't many of them be
facing jail time as well
well that but that's a quaint view of
american equality right will chamberlain
talks about
how the the media these people in dc
they're like the patrician class and
we're kind of like the peasant class
i i call it the new gym pro which is a
little absurd given you know what had
happened there but you know
it all starts a little bit early the
idea is like i know that i'm a second
class citizen
i just know it i accept it that's why
i'm not on the internet well why can't i
tweet out what would he because i can't
because i'm i'm not
fully human to them right i fully
understand i might not like it but i get
it
so when you understand that if you're
perceived as a conservative right-wing
you're not a human being to these people
then they don't care if your building's
burned down they care that they're
capital building which is by the way
taxpayer-funded
as an american i'm way more outraged
that some mom can't feed her
kids because her business was built down
then i care that something like
taxpayer-funded building is gonna have
to be
prepared that's all taxpayer money
anyway but but that's a very
outdated and archaic model of all of us
being equal as america no that's
i i agree and i say it all the time like
what's the point of me doing a video
where i'm like look at this double
standard
duh we all know it these these now i
mean
granted we're seeing this really
hilarious thing where the new york times
and slate you know
personnels are getting fired they're
losing that protection as well
so i will say there is some optimism in
that regard that they're eating
themselves faster and faster
to the point where they might there
might just not be whatever it is they're
doing the establishment media the soft
power
will be going away well if all you do is
hypocrisy then yeah you're you're like
that's a conservative cliche there's
that meme here lies
conservatism and then the the headstone
says something like imagine if it were a
democrat
but there's this other uh lindsay
something or another i realize people on
twitter don't even know their names but
he said the idea is you're just putting
um you're putting
sand in the gears so the idea is i know
for a fact that it annoys chris cuomo
and jake taper and these people they do
get annoyed now are they going to change
their minds are they going to be better
not really but it annoys them and
sometimes all you can do
as a second class citizen as somebody
who's essentially without
institutional power you can just annoy
these people a little bit and then you
have
you know an instance like chris promo
where he melts down on a guy threatens
to throw a guy down the stairs and
you know he's completely losing it so
you know that you know that he's
bothered by it
that's sometimes all you can do and i
think that's worth doing but for someone
like you or other people like ben
shapiro or you look or just any anybody
with a big platform
when that's all i see in your time i'm
like oh my god
go go do something especially when
people have money that's when i get
really triggered
like when it's trump campaign people
it's like okay you guys raised 250
million dollars post-election
to investigate whatever you're going to
investigate why don't you take
i mean you know what it costs take 25
million dollars and
you could hire a full-arm you
investigative reporters like oh well why
doesn't cnn cover this
i don't know why don't you hire 50
reporters though
they don't really care but no they don't
really exactly that's the scam and
that's where i get into it with mega
people because
you know what it costs i know what it
costs everybody here knows what it costs
so we're like look they got 250 million
dollars dude you're gonna give them more
money
you are an idiot that's what i tell them
and people don't like to hear that but
they could take a million dollars and
hire
eight nine ten reporters i mean you
don't gotta give them six figures
hire 20 and give them all 40 something
thousand a year and people will do it
right now people have lost their jobs
you can find people to do this
but you're right they had 250 million
dollars i don't think they actually
really cared more importantly i think
trump cared
but people around him certainly did not
and weren't there to help him they were
there to extract as much as they could
from him and
well he fell for it i mean he fell for
it but moreover the the problem that i
had
is like the donors fell forward i'm
always like demand more of your leaders
i think that's why again i differ from a
lot of trump people is
the idea is like if you go to bed
tonight and you wake up
you're not gonna be like oh god i just
had mike on my show and he's tweeting
and bombs
what indigestion you're never gonna wake
up with indigestion
that's how you should be if you're uh
if you're trump you should just realize
okay i don't want my people to wake up
with indigestion i know people like to
have a lot of fun
i know that we should keep it light i
know they like a little bit of trolling
but i don't want people just to wake up
with the complete case of
what you know what did i really do and
trump would kind of do that over and
over again and that's where he became
his own worse than me or even stuff like
early on i i never liked was the beefing
with lebron james like you're president
now dude
yeah you don't get to you can be for
lebron james in 2015.
in 2018 guess what you don't get to do
that anymore or slam dunking on rosie
while his supporters are being kicked
off the internet
there's a famous saying that there's a
meme about that says people who believe
in politicians think that strippers
actually like them
they don't politicians don't like you
either and a lot of them sadly are being
used for their personal benefit and
a lot of it is not being done for
yearbooks well let's let's do that let's
use that to jump into this next story
which uh i pulled up the best source
imaginable for this is the independent
women's forum
they say feminist author and former bill
clinton advisor naomi wolf warns of
totalitarianism
because of pandemic emergency rules it's
really interesting because
naomi wolf voted for joe biden then came
out later saying if i had known he was
in favor of lockdowns i wouldn't have
done it
the dude was screaming high heavens he
was in favor of lockdown he was the
plexiglass
president yeah literally that was what
he was named after
so it was surprising to see this kind of
tweet it did go viral because it did
garner a lot of attention
but you know there's a lot of things we
could criticize them but this is a
moment where she's finally coming out
and actually speaking some bigger truths
out there she was just on tucker carlson
and some of the points she's making are
ryan on the head and i have to agree
with her when she says that lockdowns
are
as the mexican president said tools of
totalitarians what i find interesting
about this
is one i will always give credit where
credit is due
calling out totalitarianism and the
lockdowns and all stuff is a good thing
but i do have to at least have some
critical view
i mean does she really care or is she
just making money off of
anti-establishment sentiment
when it was trump in office trump was
bad and then immediately the day
after they call it for biden she goes oh
oh oh oh biden is bad too
oh yeah dude like the reason i bring
this up is because luke you made that
point about strippers
that you know the people who trust
politicians are the same people who
think that strippers like them
is naomi wolfe just another one of these
personalities who's going to try and say
whatever she has to say
i would contest that from my own
personal experiences understanding that
the anti-establishment
dollar is not really a high dollar it's
not really valued a lot
and now the the establishment dollar
which means
talking about their narratives and their
talking points that pays a lot that has
a lot of gigs so
i think she's actually putting a lot on
the line by criticizing biden because
she's one of the few that actually does
and there's not many other people like
her
and i don't think i honestly think she
didn't know the um
my wife's parents my in-laws i guess you
call them
because they're from iran cnn has
actually good reputation internationally
the biggest problem with cnn isn't
domestic because internationally people
actually believe that stuff
and it really is harming the country and
the country's interests
so they don't know they'll come over and
bring up things and we're like
yeah you know that this thing happened i
have no idea that it happened
so i do believe people like naomi wolf
are so secluded
that she didn't know i mean something
came out too robbie so i've uh tweeted
it out i think skeptic mag did the
survey but
if you ask most violent voters how many
unarmed black men do you think are
killed a year
by police they're going to say a
thousand yeah i think we actually we
actually have this
there's a cell you tweeted about that
zach goldberg tweeted about it
interestingly there's this graph i
also posted on instagram they asked
people in 2019 what percentage of people
killed by police were black
very liberal people said 60 they thought
60
of the people killed by police were
black conservatives said 37
the real number 23 even conservatives
were overestimating but the crazy thing
you're referencing
is in one of the graphs if you ask a
very liberal person
how many black men were killed by cops
in 2019 31
of very liberals will say about 1 000
30 will say about 100 and then among
conservatives
46 percent say about 10 40 say about a
hundred
i think the real number was uh 20 20 17
years yeah
and that's where you know this is what
probably where the mindset work comes in
is
a lot of persuasion or mindset is
meeting people where they are
so i know that if i'm talking to a biden
person like naomi wolf
i'm meeting her where she is which she
believes that literally there's a
thousand
unarmed black people being killed and
that's why they're so
you know because i'd be freaking out too
if there were a thousand unarmed black
people being killed a year in the
country
i would be marching with them too right
i would i would be right there but when
you actually look at you're like well
i mean it's 19 to 25 twice as many
white people are actually killed nobody
knows their names
there's actually a bit of that in the
hoax movie was ask how many people
name one white guy who was killed the
best i can do is i think it was in san
bernardino a homeless guy got beat to
death and you could see the pictures of
his face swollen
up but that's the closest that i can
come to finding the name
right even though numerically we should
know at least as many but we really
don't
so when you look at the numbers you have
a different perspective
on how things are going so you have to
meet people where they are this is what
they believe
so this could just be naomi wolfe
getting the red pill
basically she's been she's been eating
up mainstream media trash
and then something happened after the
seventh where she saw some news that she
trusted and said
wait a minute what and she finally woke
up to what was really going on well
she's been
anti-establishment for a while she also
uh said a lot of supportive things for
the second amendment and and told people
to reconsider their thoughts on the left
about
being able to defend yourself and bear
arms i interviewed her before
so there is a shifting but i think again
we we have to stop thinking between the
left and the right we have to start
thinking
establishment versus anti-establishment
and overall
i think she's been on the
anti-establishment trend and i think
should be some someone interesting to
talk to about this specifically
so crazy to get into her mind and
understand where she came from
and what changes her opinions you just
said it's anti-establishment to support
the second amendment
the the most established document in the
united states somehow is
anti-establishment
that's true that's insane yeah every one
of these politicians are doing
everything in their power to destroy it
because it constrains them then it
sounds like they're not in our best
interests
it's it's like over the past several
hundred years the the people have had a
giant
shield the constitution and every day a
politician
is just battering against it trying to
destroy it and justify
their their ability to do so if we don't
i guess uh i don't know i don't know the
exact quote
if we don't defend the constitution then
the constitution will no longer defend
us
it's just like multinational corporate
bribes yeah
but in that uh in that regard nami wolf
is absolutely correct about the
totalitarianism
and i'm glad at least some people are
waking up to it joe biden
is going to be doing all of these things
that they complained about that
with trump you know kids in cages
congratulations that's all back
it's actually back with a vengeance now
they've got more facilities
before it was donald trump using was it
the homestead facility in in in southern
miami
and that was built on the obama
administration right they complained
about it and now lord and as a lawyer
too not to interrupt just to chime in
under the law they actually have to that
was something left out of the reporting
there was something called the flores
decision
which is that you can't keep kids and
adults together in the same facility
so the whole thing as you said started
with obama because of this ninth circuit
ruling
carried under trump and biden's doing it
but it's like but
it's not just that so so trump inherits
the homestead facility and the left is
screaming and complaining he's got kids
in cages
and they kept accidentally posting
photos of obama-era stuff
but joe biden just he opened a new one
didn't he they have these new
these new uh mobile units with bars on
the windows
they look like an air conditioning yeah
overflow facilities overflow
migrant youth overflow facility now
here's a funny thing
i'm gonna defend joe biden on this one
when donald trump
uh under his administration you had
these kids being separate from the
adults
we don't know who their parents are
right so do you really want these kids
to potentially be with strangers because
strangers do that
sometimes it's horrifying we want to
make sure families are not separated
but what if you have some dude who can't
prove who his kid is and the kid says
that's not my dad
so they separate the kids and then the
life gets mad joe biden
is doing the same thing the left is
complaining about joe biden doing this
now and i'm going to say the same thing
we can't just assume because some guy
said that that's my kid
it's that's true and we got to be
careful about trafficking so what do we
do
yeah being in mexico many times you see
all these wanted posters and all these
missing children posters
all over the public streets and there's
an epidemic of missing children
in mexico that's a lot higher than a lot
of people even understand
and covering the border crisis
specifically in tijuana there's been
many stories of children being stolen
so they could use it as a way to get
across the border and to get sympathy
and there's this fake news being spread
around that if you come across the
border with it with a child that you're
going to be allowed in
allowed through without any problems
without any questions as long as you
have a child so
there's stories like this it's not
always uh you know the the
it doesn't always 100 of the time happen
but it does happen and it does need to
be addressed and sadly
this you know the child trafficking and
kidnapping in mexico
deserves to be a lot of a bigger story
than it actually is
i guess the the main issue with
everything we've been talking about
is people you you look you said it was
establishment versus anti-establishment
i don't even think that's true i think
it's people who only watch mainstream
media versus people who actually think
critically
zombies well you have to look deep
though i mean
again you know i have a lot of
compassion for people it's just
imagine if you don't go into the weeds
to look
into everything yourself it's like a
full-time job practically
so that's that's why you know the they
attack youtube and everything else is
the idea that that you're a working mom
or a working dad and you come home after
a long shift and you got three hours and
you hope to see your kids before they go
to bed
and you're gonna say oh i wonder what
really is going on with these overflow
facilities oh there was actually a
ruling called the flores decision and
you can't have unaccompanied minors
because human trafficking and there was
a report actually
to your point luke there was actually a
report that showed that hundreds of
children had been
human trafficked and had been let go
back to their traffickers so that this
is all
not conspiracy it's all true but you're
just trying to get by man you're just
trying to live
and that's why i i think that's because
i grew up very poor
i think that's why i loathe the media in
a way that i take it personally which is
people are just trying to work man
people are just trying to get by people
are trying to live the best life that
they can and be moral
and be compassionate and you're lying to
them you're creating hysteria
you're making people think that if
you're a black guy and you leave your
house
you might be hunted down by the police
that day because thousands of people are
being killed every day
you're creating a horrible horrible
mental state for people
and i resent that trauma fear pain and
once you put that in someone's mindset
once you attract that once you make them
think that they're a victim
i mean they're going to start acting
like it and your mindset is
critically uh important that's why you
know you wrote your book this way but
another thing that that kind of gave me
hope recently and i started my video
today with this
was a clip from the australian open and
it's a clip of a lady
talking about how great the vaccine is
and we're all going to go back to normal
because of the vaccine and the crowd
erupted
really huge booze at the australian open
and then she said
we want to thank our government bigger
booze bigger i
i tweeted the video also uh lukewarm
change if you want to pull it up but the
video is
eye-opening and mind-boggling to see so
many people during the australian open
just absolutely boo as loud as they can
this person trying to thank the
government and the vaccine for bringing
life back to normal
and it was something that literally awe
struck me and made me really consider
like hey maybe
maybe people are far more awake than we
than we understand
um i don't know if you could play the
full clip because copy copyrights
oh yeah maybe not uh you should be
careful with that but
uh when you play the video i mean the
booze are so loud there's there's
no even questioning it i think you
played the first 15 seconds
an extraordinary sacrifice for everyone
and with vaccinations on the way
rolling out in many countries around the
world it's now a time for optimism and
hope for the future
yeah wow it was even bigger booze when
she was like we want to thank the
government they
they even went crazier but don't play
the full clip because you know you've
got to be careful
but seeing that clip gave me chills
because it's like wait wait people are
are far more awake people are far more
aware than we give them credit
to and we're seeing a perception of
reality that's catered to us by
algorithms by big tech billionaires
and that's another perspective you need
to entertain you know who i think the
most dangerous man right now in the
country is
well okay that's hyperbolic i should say
that but you know what you you want to
know who i think is
one of the most dangerous people in the
country dr fauci uh you know what oh
yeah i
think but well let me tell you exactly
why he is going out saying
that even if you get the vaccine nothing
will will change
you still have to social distance you
stop the mass you still
you still can't reopen your business the
people that are saying
that the vaccine will not do anything
for us
are telling people not to get it and
that's fauci doing that
so i talk to people and i ask my friends
are you gonna get the vaccine they're
like why what's the point
and i'm like what do you mean what's the
point so who cares foul she said
nothing's going back to normal
and i'm like why is this this guy saying
these things
he's making people not want to go and
actually take care of themselves well he
was telling people too in march
20 20 nobody believes me and then i say
here's the article
oh you can go on a cruise ship
everything's fine so if you look at
anything that he said the guy is kind of
an idiot i think jordan schnackdle or
whatever i'm really bad with names
um as you'll learn is actually people
thought it was a bit where i'd
mispronounce names to be like alpha and
like
no i just really don't know names i just
really am that bad
and there fauci has just fallen upon his
entire government career
he's actually not an impressive person
when you watch him talk
more than one time beyond the all he can
do is talk in buzzwords oh you know the
world's not going to turn to normal
talk about math talk about the numbers
talk about the models you gave
he's not going to do it and like you
said he he unintentionally
presents a case against vaccinations
because you're like ah do i really want
to do this i was on the line
nothing's going to change anyway i'm
going to keep doing and that that's
government though i mean the the lesson
of corona
honestly man was you know you watch
those movies
independence day the world rallies
together competent people
rise up you have a kind of a solution to
things our technocrats are just
idiots they're they're just not even
competent to being technocrats
and fauci is a great example is that's
who we'd be ruled by
i'd rather be ruled by biden to be
honest than fouchy if i had to choose
yeah well he keeps contradicting himself
even recently with the mask thing he
said
there's no evidence that you should wear
two masks now he says you should wear
hold on the first thing he said was it's
just common sense that two masks would
be better yeah then he came out later
said well there's nothing saying that
two masks would be better
and then he came out again saying two
masks are better than the cdc issues a
guideline saying where two masks yeah he
also said that all
the vaccines will be available for
everyone by april he now changed that to
june he was telling everyone not to wear
masks he was talking about
airborne transmissions he was talking
about so many things that he was
absolutely wrong
on and yet he's still being played by
brad pitt he's still being portrayed as
some kind of religious
god figure to some people i mean the
worship of this man is absolutely
sickening they have to though which is
go to your point your point earlier
the you know michael mal says that which
is the propaganda wouldn't be necessary
if they're
winning it's just so unbelievable people
are so dumb
think about how crazy it is that fauci
literally came out and said
he fouchy said this don't wear a mask he
said no you don't need a mask
you don't need to go do that and then he
came out later saying oh you got to wear
a mask then he came out saying wear two
then don't wear two then wear two
now the cdc says where where to wouldn't
any
regular person like you you described
mike who just wants to go home spend
some time with their kids
eventually be like i can't take it
anymore
you can't tell me what is going on or
why and you keep changing everything
at a certain point you'd be like there's
no way you expect me to do both oh and
over 30 people are
um so that's the divide i notice is
there's an outdoor gym because orange
county is pretty much life
as normal where i live because the
sheriff's like we're not going to take
it people and arrest people
for you know governor newsom sorry not
going to do it so we have an outdoor gym
and the boomers rarely wear their masks
except you have to when you check in and
you check out the under 30 people in
between their little sets they're
wearing the masks
so the majority of the people especially
if you're not even red blue but just the
majority of people are done with it
majority of the people are what do i got
to do okay do i got to wear a mask to
check and i'm going to check in
but they don't actually respect falci
but you go to la
you go to these deep blue areas 30 year
old people they're they're actually
enforcing imagine being a 30 year old
man
and you're yelling at someone to wear a
mask or
you're you're wearing a mask and then
you lift your mask up take a bite of a
cheeseburger and then pull the mask down
while you chew and you're getting food
bits all over your mask like some kind
of [ __ ]
that's it that's insane evidence that
covet exists in ice cream and just let
it go
right past you because your cognitive
dissonance like it's in the food supply
my point about fauci is that i don't
expect the average person
to do all the research that i do every
day right they're not
researchers they're they're plumbers
they're they're custodians or carpenters
or computer technicians or managers or
car salesmen whatever
i i work all day reading the stuff so i
know and then many people come to this
show to try and get a critical
assessment because
that's not their job right i wouldn't i
wouldn't think i could go on the
internet and learn how to be a plumber i
can try and do a tutorial i'm going to
hire a plumber to be honest i need the
expert to do it
so what what i'm saying is there are
people who could you could turn the tv
on
and you have anderson cooper sitting
there with his glasses and he's like dr
fauci you say don't wear a mask and
fouchy goes don't wear a mask don't wear
them
and it's like no no no that was crazy
you need to
then he comes out later saying to wear a
mask then he comes out saying two
then don't wear two then wear two then
the cd sees his wear too
wouldn't a regular person at some point
just be like i don't even know what it's
supposed to do anymore because i keep
changing what i'm supposed to do
i think that's where they are though i
guess that's what that's what i've
observed is that
that's where the average kind of regular
person is
and it's only the people who live in
these information silos
the the woke kids in brooklyn or because
again that
just as a meta point is i remembering a
30 year old man
you if you'd have told me to wear a mask
and i was probably more liberal when i
was 30.
i would say what are you doing like do i
have to do it i guess i will because you
got to do what you got to do
me being a being a man and yelling at
another man
when you're walking outside walking your
dog you need to wear a mask
is another bigger bigger problem but if
you look at just
public sentiment public cinema is where
you is people are people are kind of
tired of it have you seen that video
where there's a woman she's in a she's
in a store
and there's a guy basically harassing
her and it reveals everything when he
goes
does anybody else think it's it's messed
up that she doesn't have to wear a mask
but we do
right now you know what the guy was
really mad about he's mad that they got
his their their boot on his neck
and he can't do anything about it so he
harasses some five foot tall woman who's
not wearing a mask
yeah crabs in a bucket um crabs in a
bucket mindset they don't want to
they don't want to do it but everybody
has to do it they're going to do it but
yeah sentiment sentiments changed man
people are mad
that's why they're doing more and more
of suppressing information that's why
people like the new york times
unfettered conversations are happening
this is bad you don't you shouldn't have
to scold people
if your message is credible because most
people can kind of observe the world
like you even if you work
and you work hard and people tell you
okay man-made global warming is caused
by carbon emissions and you're like okay
but wait but you're flying a private jet
you have a beachfront property you're
buying beachfront property but wait a
minute you're going to be under water
here in martha's vineyard and you spent
15 million dollars on your home
so there's such a disconnect between the
messaging from the ruling elite
and how they actually live their lives
that more and more people are frustrated
do you think these regular people
who are kind of just like getting
shocked out of the system because the
media is full of it do you think they're
they're going to reject all this
wokeness because it kind of feels like
it's just sweeping over everything like
the critical theory and all that stuff
well that's why they're again trying to
push it in an educational thing
that's why the media is pushing it so
hard and having their little purges
because
you know because we read media even
though we read it critically we're
gaslit we're still victims because we
still think this is over represented
because that's what we look at all day
even even to say like this is wrong
we're still like
for so for example if you read the
internet i'm a pretty like hated guy
right oh yeah
i get recognized almost every day even
in even these little smaller areas that
go and it's always positive
even if it's negative a guy just kind of
like laughs nobody actually
really thinks i'm a scary person people
be like oh certain
school you know kind of like one of
those but nobody but on the internet i'm
like a very very
scary guy but that's gas lighting that's
not how people actually think
in microcosm that's the same thing with
the macrocosm people are like this is
live one of my favorite things is how if
you right now state
you've tweeted before you're in favor of
universal healthcare right yeah yeah
pretty you know yeah i could i get
people are like oh
andrew yang universal income i'm like
well you can read a political article
about me in 2017 where i was
talking about universal basic income and
my problem
with that more was like the incentives
it creates versus the idea
that i think it's good to give poor
people money but that's far right
you can you can come out and publicly
state
10 left-wing positions and then
criticize
critical race theory and what will
happen is on wikipedia
people will say hey mike cernovich has a
whole bunch of left-wing populist
positions and they'll say well he's not
a good
source you can't use him as a reference
is there a credible article
and then you will tweet critical race
theory is a bad thing and they will use
it and say well he said it so it's what
he believes he better include it he's a
far
right alt-right whatever what what you
say only matters if it's bad for you
if you're saying things against the the
cathedral well yeah what
what the cathedral does though is that
again that was part of the gas lighting
so the gas lighting is that
if you're me and you believed the
internet because you read the news even
though you know the news is a lie you'd
be like oh man you know people don't
really like me
and you're like where are these people
you know literally where are these
people i've walked down manhattan
never had i've been in the most populous
like lefty areas
and i get the el chapo kind of irony bro
like
or something like that nobody's like oh
my god that's a scary purse
because the the idea when they the carca
which is so funny is
if i were a scary person you would not
write about me
right you don't see these people these
woke boys in brooklyn
writing about actually scary people like
prison gangs not writing about
hebdo yeah exactly they're not right
about charlie habdor they're not even
writing about like even these people are
like oh yeah there's all these
you know racists everywhere then go
write about the aryan brotherhood
go knock on the door ms-13 yeah yeah go
write about ms-13 so if they were
actually
frayed then they wouldn't even write
about it so that
that again translates to everything
which is the media they
they lie so much that even when you're
criticizing them you still have a form
of
a victimization of your mind because
you're like oh yeah this is predominant
opinion
no this isn't this isn't even
predominant left wing the critical race
theory i think it's not even
predominantly left-wing
i went to portland i was actually kind
of worried went to parks i've been to
berkeley berkeley was
was was kind of creepy but i walked
around with berkeley with no problems at
all
although someone did try starting a
fight with me at a skate park which was
crazy and then some other intermediate
but i went to portland
portland is like antifa central and i
was worried i was like
i'm gonna get some someone's gonna yell
at me and guess what happened
so this guy starts walking up to me and
i'm like oh man oh here we go
and he walks up and he goes oh it's in
pool nice to meet you man shakes my hand
and he's like big fan i love what you do
and i was like i appreciate it and i was
like is that like you you think a lot of
people in portland feel that way he's
like oh yeah definitely a
bunch of my friends watch your stuff and
i was like oh that's really neat
i go to a restaurant i'm sitting at the
bar and i order like a spicy chicken and
bacon i'm like i'm all excited and the
guy brings my sandwich out it looks
amazing and he goes hey aren't you tim
pool
and i went oh i can't eat this now yeah
this guy and then he was like i'll be
right back and i was like oh dude what
he comes out and gives me a free bottle
of hot sauce he's like dude i love your
stuff man it's fantastic
and i was like oh wow thank you and i'm
like it all these people online who say
all these nasty things
where are they unit it is it's really
simple actually
what the internet has done let's say if
let's say every city in the country
let's say let's say there's a hundred
cities and
sixty percent of the people in these
cities are regular
middle of the road people and then 30
percent are more politically active
liberal or conservative but still fairly
normal and then you have one person
who's crazy extremist that one person
goes online and finds the one person in
every other city
and creates a network of 100 people to
harass you you then start feeling like
there's a larger coming after you but
when you go out
these places most people are like oh
yeah i heard about you yeah cool how's
it going
and it's just totally normal do me a
favor guys tweet out some love to tim
and mike and luke
i don't i don't care because it's i
think the la the crap the negativity
gets shouted out because
you feel it you're angry it's easy
you're motivated but the love
it's important that you send that too i
just i've been on ayahuasca too many
times
like i've i've been confronted with all
of the things known and unknown
by god like telling me this is what you
need to work on
so then when people on the internet are
like nipping at me
it doesn't on an emotional level it just
doesn't have any kind of
like i i i and and i got to say
something too like there's no need to do
that i don't check my mentions maybe
like once or twice periodically if i
tweet something and it shows me the
tweet and the thing you know messages
come in
but i why do i care about what like you
know
some anime cat girl on twitter thinks
about what i should do with my business
like this person with 14 followers who
says dumb things i'm like you're doing
great for yourself i think i'll take my
own advice on this one
well what it does though is yeah i guess
to your point is
it it does gaslight you a little bit
where it doesn't like i don't
oh man there's a lot of people in there
not being mean to me you know i'm really
sad
but it's more like wow i'm a really
hated guy you start to believe it right
because that's all you see like wow man
people really do hate me
and because i'll be a shut-in where i
hardly ever leave my house and then
leave my house people like oh man love
your stuff blah blah blah
so it it it does create this kind of
construct where
you because you only hear one messaging
even though emotionally it doesn't
regulate or
mess with you that's true though there
was a really funny moment where uh you
retweeted something from me
i tweeted something and it was not i
remember what it was but it wasn't like
super pro trump or anti-trump it was a
political thing that was like cultural
and i thought it was more like a
libertarian issue it was something about
freedom free speech
you retweeted it and then some lefty
started responding
saying like look at all the people who
are responding you all of these
you know far right whatever and i was
like i said something like
uh people retweet tweets like i don't my
people follow whatever they want to
follow and they said if you really
did believe in freedom then you would
have left-wing people coming in here and
commenting and then all of a sudden
there were like
50 to 100 responses from people who
follow me saying oh yeah i'm a liberal i
follow tim
we just don't tweet we like mind our own
business regular people
aren't trying to scream at you on the
internet and so
what do you see online the lunatics the
ones who are screaming the loudest and
that i got to be honest that includes
each and every one of one of us in this
room
we are more more likely to be egocentric
or narcissistic than the average person
that's a fact
that's a good point that you're making
here and i was going to add that to ian
also just like negative comments hurt
you too many good comments hurt you as
well because they build up your ego and
this perception and this identity that
you're you're perfect and you have no
imperfections and that everything you do
your farts smell like roses no matter
what you eat uh no matter how many taco
bells you go to
it doesn't matter but i i think for the
most part the internet is a negative
place
you're not getting a lot of people
saying like dude i really love you
you're so fantastic you get them
sometimes
but angry it's the same thing though
where
if if you go through life and you get
like good service or something
you rarely write like a thank you card
to the person because one of the
exercises i did early on
um when i was an angry guy maybe 19 you
know you do these at home dvd
or cds that's how you had to do it and
one exercise was like a gratitude
exercise so if you went to the airplane
and like somebody was really nice to you
you would write a letter to the manager
but it was like a good letter
like say one good thing about antifa
oh uh they have a lot of money
i don't know that's a compliment so i i
will say i'll say this actually there
was a guy
he actually went to jail went to prison
he attacked someone
outside of one of my events in new york
and he apologized to the guy he attacked
he still felt morally justified in what
he did
and he said he didn't regret it but it
was more like oh i didn't realize i was
hitting a civilian you know kind of
thing oh wow
but when i read his stuff he wrote with
a great level of sensitivity
in a great level of empathy
but he believe he just believes things
about the world that aren't true
and that's again where they they read
things on the internet they don't
actually talk i'm like hey dude
you can give me a call bro like you can
give me a call and you can say hey mike
do you like believe these things before
you want to riot and i'll honestly tell
you what i believe or what i don't
believe
so some of them do have a above average
amount of literacy above average amount
of compassion above
average amount of cultural awareness
midwifes
but you know the the the thug element
you know because if you're like white
and you want to be
in a gang you join in tifa because you
can kind of get away with it right is
that it's like a life hack
do you want to be violent you can join
the hell's angels which
you're actually around really tough guys
and that maybe you're not tough enough
to do that
or you can join in tifa and you have a
license to
to beat people up and you're going to
even be defended by merrick garland
there you go celebrities will endorse
you in support
i'm partly kidding with the antifa thing
but i've said it a couple times because
i i really don't like what these people
have done a lot of them the violence
but i also think it's really dangerous
if we only ever go down the path of
demonization
we have to recognize these people you
know the saying goes that
the left the right thinks the left is
misguided but the left thinks the right
is evil
and we need to make sure that that
there's always i think there's always a
path to redemption
well i think typically there's a
tendency towards
a path of redemption some people are
just like it's too far gone and you're
like
you know i don't know what we can do for
this person but i look at a lot of these
activists and i
i had a conversation with an antifa guy
in berkeley he was
screaming at like some right wing dude
and i was filming
and then once things started to calm
down i asked him you know tell me what
was going on what were you saying
he started explaining he's like oh so
this guy's here and i'm saying this and
then we started walking
back down towards the park where they
were doing that rally and he was like
these people are all fascists man you
got to understand and i said you think
these people are all fascists
and he's like yes i do and i said do you
think these people love the second
amendment
he's like well yeah of course i was like
why do you think they love the second
amendment
they're always complaining about the
government trying to take over and i was
like
well that sounds like they're scared of
fascism and he was like
wait wait i mean no they're fascist and
i was like bro i think they're scared of
fascism as you are
and he was like oh i'm like that's that
moment he no one ever told him that
so maybe maybe there's a chance to like
you know these people aren't getting
real news like naomi wolf right
she's getting this bad information and
then she goes on tucker and she's like i
can't believe how wrong i was and i'm
like
thank you very much welcome to the fight
that's that's the right thing to do or
they could go to boeing they could go to
boeing's house there's just so many
you could go to the raytheon ceo house
they wouldn't even know they're yeah
that to me is why all of this stuff is
sort of empty is at least when they were
doing the wto protest in seattle
okay okay you're actually fighting the
system you're actually fighting the
establishment
i don't agree with your tactics i don't
agree with writing but hey i can
actually see that
but going to disrupt andy knows book
sale
apollo books is to me just okay you're
not you're not fighting the system bro
right right he's just like he's dude
he's he's the child of immigrants who
wrote a book he's one guy he has no
institutional power
well let's do this let's talk about the
gas lighting because we we did briefly
mention this but i want to i want to
dive deeper into this the story
because a lot of these antifa people are
motivated by fake news
so uh earlier on we were talking about
this we have this poll
this is uh from zach goldberg he says a
recent nationally representative survey
commissioned by skeptic mag
asked respondents to estimate the number
of unarmed blacks killed by police in
2019.
overall 44 of liberals guessed 1 000 or
more
as compared to 20 of conservatives this
calculation
is based on the crosstabs shared with me
by the researcher this is this this is
crazy man i watched
a prageru video and it was will whit i
think it was wilbur
and he's at the venice skate park in
california and there's three black dudes
and he asks them
how many black people do you think were
killed by cops in 2019
and one guy goes thousands man thousands
and he was like you think thousands the
other guy's like yeah probably thousands
maybe more
and then he was like 19. depend
depending on which statistic you use
so this skeptic mag used the higher
number of 27 because they take into
account
more more circumstances i think the the
official number of
unarmed black men shot and killed is
like 13
but then when you take into
consideration like maybe like chokeholds
and stuff like that it goes up to about
27
27 each and every one of those unarmed
individuals who died
is a nightmarish tragedy i
i i don't even believe the death penalty
man i i really don't i think if you've
subdued someone
then we have to deal with like how i
don't i don't have all the answers i
just tell you this
i think if we got someone locked in a
box and you're like now we're going to
kill you i think that's insane
they're no longer a threat you got them
locked you're locked in in this prison
so i'm opposed to that so if a cop comes
out and
gets into a situation and someone dies
that's that's a nightmare scenario
because
we have a constitution we have a bill of
rights we're innocent until proven
guilty
but i also recognize that these cops
aren't going out hunting people down
but that's the narrative you're getting
from the media these young people then
believe it the craziest thing about the
story
this other chart we brought up take this
out when they asked conservatives
what percentage of people killed by
police were black that conservatives had
37.8
that's the number is actually 23 23.4
23.4 percent of the people who were
killed by cops in 2019 were black
even conservatives overestimate the
total number by about 50
so whatever is going on with the media
that even conservatives
are skeptical of they're still buying
into these narratives
well it's visual it's because of visual
persuasion the
a very non-political way that that
survey was done is
if you pulled the american public and
you said what presidential population
you think is why
you know hispanic black most people
would say they think one in four people
in america are black
and if you ask them what percentage of
population is gay you get something from
like five to 25 percent
and the answer is that well if you if
you're doing a billboard you have four
people
you can't put four white people because
that'd be racist so you have to put
you know okay we need a woman here we
need a black here we need a gay person
here
you know we have all the representation
and then people see that over and over
and over and over again
so that that misunderstanding is the
same thing with combat dust if you say
hey what percentage of
combat fatalities do you think are like
female versus male and they'll be like
well like 25
or female or some high number you're
like no it's like less than one percent
yeah yeah it's like way way down the
list and that's because
medium is the message visual persuasion
even if you're
even if some a good point because i
believe in representation i believe i
agree with the left in terms of
representation matters
you should have positive role models of
every kind of
race religion represented because that
does matter because kids watch that
because
media is so important so people grew up
in the 80s and they watch action movies
they go to the gym
it's unconscious nobody's saying hey go
look like sylvester stallone but like
it's
it's there on a conscious level so i
actually believe in representation
but even when it's meant to be done in
good faith people
then draw the wrong conclusions and then
when it's done in bad faith which is
what the media is doing hands up don't
shoot
all the various hoaxes you're
terrorizing i mean
the wild thing about it is this probably
a weird thing that people wouldn't
expect me to think but i would say that
black men are the biggest victims of the
media hoaxes
because when i leave the house i you
know i know as a lawyer
if i get pulled over things to get dodgy
you should be careful all the time
i tell people that whatever you are but
i don't think that i'm gonna get hunted
down
by anyone you know i don't think that
i'm gonna get hunted down by a gang of
black teenagers or
the police or anyone else there's a
large percent of the population
there's actually somebody who worked for
the nra a black guy and he would say
that
or african-american or poc or whatever
you're allowed to say now is
he used to actually believe that white
people with guns were going to hunt him
down
what a terrible way to live man scary
man and that's because you've been
ghastly well so the the crazy thing is
when i went to sweden
there were a lot of conservative
personalities talking about the migrant
crime waves and things like that
they were showing these videos of
burning cars and the most egregious
stuff
and what i discovered was they were
right there was a crime wave in sweden
one uh uh the previous year they had a
total of one murder
the next year it went up to like 13. for
the people of the town of
the city of malma that was nightmarish
it was like why are these people being
killed
but for someone from chicago i was like
is that it
so what happens is people in the u.s
hear a story
murders are up over a thousand percent
and if you live in chicago
your perspective is based on the chicago
murder rate of being crazy
then you'd imagine your world a thousand
a thousand percent increase in murder
you'd be imagining
crazy insanity back i'm not going to
sweden but you actually go there and
you're like oh i get it
crime is up it's it's up quite a bit
this has the residents scared
but relative to where i'm from crime is
extremely and ridiculously low
so what happens is i think there are
people who
are correctly pointing out the crime
waves but basing
the reality situation off of their
personal experience in say london
where there is like more crime they then
put out videos or or new york or chicago
or baltimore
and then they make it seem because in
their world view
it is crazy to see this massive increase
in murders for people who lived in
sweden
they were shocked by these numbers but
they're not used to it
so their their fear was legitimate when
these people in sweden would say we're
terrified to go outside
they mean it but it's not the same thing
you know if you're not from there you
wouldn't know
well and a lot of that's in good faith
too which is
why like i'll give you an example like i
used to be because i grew up in a small
town
terrified of big cities right i wouldn't
want to go to new york and get shot
gonna go chicago to get mugged and then
i started traveling more
and then i would meet people from the
city who are afraid of the country we'd
be driving down they're like oh my god
country roads is this going to be the
texas chainsaw massacre
is it going to be deliverance all over
again so there there is the other rising
where
okay i grew up in the rural area and
actually it's incredibly dangerous in
terms of driving car accidents a deer
runs out and i'm afraid of going to
chicago to go shopping a miracle mile
i'm actually safer in miracle mile that
i am driving my car at night
because some deer is not going to you
know run out of the road so that's not
even malicious
but then with the media because there's
all these cognitive biases
the availability bias of the last thing
you hear is what you think happens all
the time so for example
there was that famous case where the the
airline pilot
like i think captain sullivan or sully
landed in water
and then after he landed in water oh my
god an emergency
we have to now have water life life
jackets and every kind of plane you're
like
that happened one time in 10 years yeah
you know but but if you're the guy who
says that happened one time in 10 years
it is what it is now you're gonna be
massacred by the media oh you don't care
if
kids drown in a pool so that that's
always going to happen too and it
happens to us even
when you're trying to to act in good
faith and to tell the truth
i worked at o'hare airport and they
hired
a safety coordinator guy so they have
the
the bag room where the conveyor belt
brings all of your luggage when you drop
it off
and so i guess one day this is what i
was told i don't know if it's true but
this is what i was told
somebody had something on their boot and
slipped
and so the next day i come in and
they've glued
this grip down to the floor all across
the floor
and it made it a lot harder to drive
across because it was super grippy
material
and it was really funny to like walk
over it was like they took like
sandpaper glued to the floor and uh
i was like so like one guy trips and
that's their response well they don't
want to be sued
yep so if one guy got hurt the next time
someone gets hurt
they're gonna spend you know thousands
and thousands of dollars they're like
spend a couple hundred bucks and glue
the sandpaper to the floor
so it was an overreaction but it's also
i guess just we have a system built in
place where nobody wants to assume any
risks
nobody wants to recognize that sometimes
accidents happen but also some people
exploit that accident for personal gain
well you don't want to be an adult
that's where you know one of the things
i i don't like how trump will handle
coronavirus i'm not here to defend that
but like one thing he said was hey man
you know like
people died is what it is and the answer
is
yes i i mean a a lot of people are going
to die this year going to like
die different things there are
trade-offs what do you
you can't just like every death is a
tragedy i mean it is to me you know if i
die it's a tragedy to my family or
friends or whatever but if you're in a
leadership position the answer is like
yeah i mean people die dude like what
are you gonna do you stop the world
you shut everything down because people
are gonna die but then if you say that
now you're a monster
oh this person doesn't care about anyone
he's killing grandma that's that's
that's the scary reality of what's going
on is that everything has to be perfect
all the time like i see these tweets
from aoc
and she you know there was like some
lefty who said
uh what do they say no one should ever
have to live in poverty right
and it was like someone responded a
person that's a viral tweet
a person who was working full-time
should not be living in poverty and they
responded with a snapback
no one should be living in poverty
poverty is relative
poverty 100 years ago was like people
sleeping in a mud pit
and rockefeller had had garbage dental
care now
poor people in this country are
overweight and have air conditioning and
refrigerators and tvs
that's look i'm not saying life is great
for them i would like to see them live
better i would like to see the standard
go up but the standard is going up
if no one can ever live in poverty well
i don't know tell you man because it's
relative
well and luke's been around you know
like i thought i grew up poor and like
i you know i got the creds to say i grew
up poor and then i went cambodia and i
was like all right dude
you had a yard bro you had a yard you
didn't really grow up poor
yeah i mean traveling to places like
philippines and africa and somalia it
really gives you a lot of different
perspectives but you
you were also born in the soviet union
yeah or poland yeah uh but
but again what's happening here it's
everything's becoming so political
everything's becoming this kind of
emotional manipulative mind control
and it's being played over and over
again just to make sure that we are
convinced that something is happening
when we look at the way that the media
has been acting they've been acting
very very intelligently when it comes to
their propaganda
there's a reason they repeated the
george floyd murder tape
over and over and over again and when we
talk about you know that particular
event whether you have questions about
it or not
it brought up a lot of emotions for a
lot of people
that a lot of people capitalized on for
their own personal political benefit
whether it was true or not it didn't
matter people saw it and got to see it
all the time when it comes to other
people let's just say you know ashley
babbitt getting killed
you don't see that footage on cnn for a
particular reason this is why the vmware
it was on cnn they paid the guy the the
lefty activist
but as far as like the you if you
compare the footage to george floyd i
think there's a big
disparity as far as how much it's played
how it's played and the coverage behind
it
the music behind it the the zooming in
on it the face of a man dying in front
of you
is traumatic uh but we have to
understand these are selectively chosen
to have
a bigger agenda out there when you
brought up you know covid
if we treated obesity like covid cancer
like
covet the opioid epidemic like covid
especially with the number of deaths
with the number of peoples affected by
that
my goodness we would never get out of
the door ever but
covet is something else that's being
treated in this own special unique way
but obesity depression child suicide
rates all of those issues that are
effective
of of the lockdowns we're not we can't
even talk about 300 000 people die per
year from obesity
we've got to lock everything down yep we
got we got to shut it all down
it's 300 000 people diabetes i mean if
you if you factor diabetes and heart
disease and that
probably more you know if you look at it
like lifestyle what what the top 10 most
prescribed pharmaceuticals
eight out of 10 are lifestyle what are
the most what are the most incredulous
things that i saw was a pepsi
advertisement
uh saying that your next covet test is
going to be at walmart
i mean how ridiculous could yeah pepsi
was there was a pepsi advertisement that
said get your coveted test now at
walmart
and i'm like are you freaking kidding me
especially when you look at the
scientific studies there's a meme i
tweeted of this like morbidly obese guy
with all the kfc and all this fast food
and the byline says americans be like
you have no right to go outside and
endanger my health there's no real
conversations about health there's no
real conversations about stress
sleep meditation fasting supplements
making sure you get enough exercise
there's no conversations about that
but there is conversations about
restricting your freedoms taking away
your liberties taking away your money
taking away your livelihood taking away
your existence
for the benefit of the state and it's
ridiculous and it's six and it's
two-faced
and it needs to be called out more than
ever yeah so
thank you naomi kleinfer let's uh let's
sort of do like a pretty harsh segue
into this other segment that's uh
about critical race theory and social
justice stuff but it's more about uh
men and women and and child ring and
stuff i i
normally like to make sure we keep
everything in a standard through line
but this one's too interesting to pass
up because matthew iglesias
so matthew iglesias is the co-founder of
vox.com and he tweeted this today
here's a poll that could burn the
discourse down
and i don't know why he posted it but
it's
family work preference based on gender
and marital parental status
and the funny thing is i don't think
there's anything necessarily definitive
from it
but we do see that married mothers
overwhelmingly believe around 55 percent
that one parent should work full time
and one parent should provide child care
in the home
and married fathers basically think the
same thing but you know what's really
funny about this
married mothers only about 15 percent
think both parents should work full time
and use child care
work married fathers you actually have
around 25
who think both parents should be working
full-time and using paid child care
i think it's funny that more guys think
that and i think it's because men
probably underestimate the amount of
work that goes into raising kids
so they're like oh my wife can work it's
no big deal we'll get a child you know a
sitter and and the wife is like no
no you you underestimate but
interestingly
there's a poll from 2019 that matthew
also uh posted
56 percent of women prefer working to
homemaking
i think there's interesting
ramifications from this notably that the
number is actually
56 for women and uh who prefer to work
outside the home but 75 percent for men
and then 39 of women prefer being a
homemaker and only 23 percent of men
my question and what i want to just i
want to get into like just kind of the
gender dynamics especially with you here
mike
about what you think this leads to why
it's happening and yeah
we were talking about testosterone
before and like men's testosterone
levels going down so i figured it'd be
fun to talk about this
yeah those things i'm surprised the
numbers aren't inverse where
more people want to be stay-at-home moms
well one thing i've i've got with uh
sean is shauna would be a little bit
insecure to say that she was a
stay-at-home mom
because she would get like shamed by
other women for being a stay-at-home mom
but if why would you shame someone if
you were happy
right that that's where i think the
numbers are probably even
even more skewed towards they actually
don't want to work because
like think about if you're happy and
somebody says oh yeah i'm doing this
thing like me oh yeah i like to lift
weights and you tell me i like to bike
you tell me you like to run you like to
run you like to bike and i'm like i'm
glad that everybody's really happy
so she would feel like put on the spot
right because there's all this like
shame
directed by women who are like only a
stay-at-home mom
i couldn't do it i could just i know i
believe in mindset your limits blah blah
blah
i could not be all the time with the
kids the way my wife this is this is
like the the
one subject that when i when we talk
about triggers the most anger from
leftists and i don't
i mean i can probably make some
assumptions as to why they get so mad
about it because maybe it's what you
kind of pointed out that there's a lot
of women who would rather
be homemakers i mean the gallup poll
says that maybe there are more but
they're worried about being
shunned or shamed well parenting does
too so shauna
it's so interesting because i you know i
see things from her perspective too is
anything about parenting makes people
mad so for example i did a whole thread
on how we did natural childbirth and i
prefaced it with hey man if you went to
the hospital
i just hope your kids are healthy all
love blessings
love and light how dare you you're
giving misinformation about home births
and
they're yelling so anytime you do
something about parenting
you're already in the danger zone
because people take it personally
oh so you read to your kids three books
a day i only read one book a day to my
kid
you're there for saying that i'm a bad
parent like nobody nobody's telling you
that bro
we're just like hanging out so you're
already in the danger zone and then when
you talk about anything with
the idea that there's like a traditional
the gender roles might actually have a
biological route to it
now you're you've doubled it right
whatever whatever your because
if all you talked about was peaceful
parenting you would have people mad at
you well i was
thanked as a kid and i turned out you
know good so you're already there and
i'm not even saying biological component
i'm just like oh look at this poll that
says men prefer it more than
uh i'm sorry women prefer it more than
men and then
man people just light up well that's
something they're going to read that
into it though
oh they're going to go of course oh so
because they all rate you know they're
raised in like jon stewart
and john oh so what you're saying is
that
men belong and the working and women
belong in the house like bro i never
said that i mean i'm just talking about
an actual survey
so i can just say that i could not
i could not be a mom and i i don't have
to pander to women
because mine says men all blessings to
them there's an article i read
that really triggered the left and it
like seriously did they started writing
articles about it and yelling at me and
i got a bunch of people hitting me up
because it was about working women in
their 30s who couldn't find men
and i'm like maybe there is something
with this gallup poll
and this other discourse in that matthew
glaciers tweeted where if you got a guy
who's in his 30s
who's successful and attractive he's not
going to want to find a woman who
you know wants to work he wants to find
someone who can help him have a family
yeah there's a lot of things you can
misinterpret with opinions but one thing
you can't misinterpret are the financial
ramifications that cause
people to have a home where both of the
parents work it used to be that someone
would have one job and they could pay
for their family they could pay for
their mortgage they could pay for the
food on the table
now that situation is dramatically going
down especially with energy prices going
up housing prices going up
food prices going up this is affecting
us in such dramatic ways and we have to
understand behind
the larger movement especially in the
early onsets of the 1900s
there was a lot of industrialists that
saw
that if we have more taxpayers if we
have more workers if we have more
factory people
if we have more employees to choose from
wages will naturally go down and that's
why big time industrialists like
rockefeller were big time proponents
of movements that made women go into the
workforce so
there are natural incentives sure i
don't even want to go there the
financial incentives are something that
we should be having a bigger
conversation on
because these are the talking points
that do affect us and we need to realize
that in america
a single working family home cannot make
ends meet one person working
can't happen what's going to happen two
people are going to have to work and
they're going to have to rely
on illegal labor to raise their children
why
well there's a bunch of different jobs
in this country there's average media
very few that could survive and sustain
a family
what's on average i'll just tell you man
i've been blessed in life um it's hard
out there man i when i go because i
don't do a lot of the shopping
um at the at the albertson's or whatever
you should go to costco buying bulk
i went to buy halloween candy and i was
like how how is peanut m
ms you know 44 or whatever for
it goes fast when you have kids that
goes faster like diapers and everything
it's hard man so there there are some
personalities
who uh had kids when they were extremely
young
and became extremely successful i think
that one of the issues you've got a
bunch of young men
who are sitting around doing nothing
that's why jor one of the reasons i
think jordan peterson became so popular
is that he was trying to give young men
purpose
and i think it's one of the reasons why
the far left got really mad about it but
if you get a bunch of guys who are
working maybe you know let's say they're
working 40 hours a week
are they really striving and are they
providing that level of
of demand to a boss let me clarify
let's say you're 23 and you're working
at
a best buy or something you're you're
not gonna you're not gonna go to your
boss
and you know put pressure on them and
try and find more work because you're
probably making more than enough you go
home you play world of warcraft you play
destiny whatever video games you're into
minecraft or whatever
film some youtube videos maybe and then
you're done let's say you're 23 and
you've got a three-year-old kid
you're gonna go to your boss and be like
i need more money and he's gonna be like
we can't give you more money say okay
then you're gonna start looking in the
classifieds then you're gonna be like i
have no
choice i have to find something bigger
and better i i
you you literally have no choice i think
that people are missing responsible in
their lives that's that would normally
drive them to to succeed and do better
i'm not saying it's absolute i'm not
saying everybody i'm not even thinking a
majority
i'm just saying i think that is a
component for a lot of people because i
know it is hard out there
i know a lot of people struggle to make
ends meet but i also know there are a
lot of people
so i i knew i knew people back where i
grew up on the south side of chicago
who found a way to go from being a high
school dropout to making six figures
because they literally had no choice
they had a kid when they were a teenager
and they started working 80 hours a week
and then every opportunity they saw they
took they pressured their bosses and
they said
i got a kid i got to make more money and
then by the time they were 20 they were
a manager making six figures at some
company
there's that i mean there's so you
raised a lot of there's so much swirl
which is the idea that a lot of reason
reasons that young men aren't driven is
because
the dating is a disaster unless you're
like a very top-tier guy
i read some statistics on how many
people ever get matched on these dating
apps
so the the way the dating system has
it's actually kind of wild if you think
about
if you're like a top tier guy you can
have four
they're called they call them spin and
plays you can have four or five
different girls that you're dating
and they just kind of accept it like
that's the way it is and you have all
the leverage
and then if you're just like a guy who's
maybe above average a little bit above
average
you're good luck dude let me let me let
me tell you a story uh
a story and a theory hypothesis i was
talking to some like 22 year old dude
um on the east coast a year or two ago
and he was talking about how he never
had a real relationship or anything like
that and i was like man you're 22. i was
like that's kind of
to me that's crazy and uh and i started
i realized something
when i was when i was a teenager and
when i was you know partying
college years and it was just like i
drank way too much man it's a drinking
party non-stop all day i didn't go to
high school so i was just skateboarding
playing music being drunk going and
partying it was kind of wild
but the women that i would meet we
didn't have tinder
we didn't we didn't have any of these
apps so what would happen is the women i
knew in college
only knew the men they met in college so
who are the guys in college well this
this this chick's 19 years old
she knows some 19 year old guy he's not
got anything really going for me lives
in a dorm he doesn't have a car
but it's who she knows so she dates him
now he's 19 they you know become college
sweethearts or whatever maybe they get
married maybe they don't
there's a lot of people like that that's
what's happening not anymore
that's my theory so i saw this guy then
dating apps come out
now this college woman who's 19 or 20
opens up their app
and it's not just the 19 year old guy
that's what i said to this 22 year old
guys i'll tell you what your problem is
and this is not absolute i'm just saying
but i'll tell you this is something
you're really facing that i didn't face
when i was younger
i was like look i'm in my early 30s i'm
wealthy
successful i got a a a conversion rv van
i can take you to an infinity pool on a
roof of this luxury casino
and when i go on these apps how is a 19
year old college kid's going to compete
with that
so it's really simple i'm not i'm not
trying to impugn the honor of these
young women it's very it's very very
simple
if there's a 20 year old woman and she
swipes
right on this like attractive 20 year
old guy to college and they're messaging
and she's also messaging a 30 year old
guy 30 year old guy says
how would you like me to pick you up in
my you know convertible
and we'll we'll drive to my house i've
got an infinity pool i just built
and the 20 year old guy says how would
you like to come hang out at my dorm and
watch movies and she's like man which
one sounds like more fun
there's more opportunity with the guy
who's already established dating apps
have opened that up and made it much
much harder
because now young men without the status
and the wealth are competing against
established men yes and adding to that
is
the 30 year old guy isn't just texting
119 year old
so he's not just taking one off the
market which would be you know
mathematically it would all kind of suss
out he's actually taking three four
five off the market because he and he's
making them all com so it's the weird
thing is
online dating has ruined it for women
because a guy can just be like hey dude
i need nu
and if you're like no it's like okay i'm
the 35-year-old guy i'm gonna i'm about
to fly to paris
i'm picking out who i want to bring with
me on this trip you're going to send
them no
see you later going down the list of the
you have
not just your 19 year old you can't
compete but it's not just one girl's
been taken off the market now
it's really like four or five are being
taken off by the top dogs so you have
the
the top of the food chain kind of guys
having a monopoly and then you have the
younger guys who then just check out and
i want to stress too like
more power to these women it's their
choice to be with whoever they want to
be with and
and i'm not saying that there's any
violation of their autonomy or agency
simply because they're engaged in this
dating app game i'm just saying
there is a uh general hypothesis i have
that i think the math will pan out
that young men are less likely to form
bonds and relationships with women
because of the
competition in the market but then my
question is what happens when those 20
year old guys are 30 year old guys
without any dating experience but also
most importantly what's going to happen
to those 19 year old women that do
become 30.
there's this weird kind of invert axis
that happens especially around the age
of 30 i mean it's becoming later and
later on
but it's not good it's not good for men
when they're young
and it's not good for women when they're
older so this is causing a lot of
a lot of infighting that that is causing
a lot of relationships not to happen
i i gotta say too i love like this this
always really really pisses off the left
but i think it was okcupid who did the
study on
they would never do that again they were
all right they deleted them yeah yeah
they deleted these studies
it showed that i forgot what their mate
their their metrics were
but that women have maximum societal
value at young ages and men have none
and then around 28 men start going up
and uh it's around 22 men start going up
and around 22 women
uh uh i think 22 is where like their
highest point yeah they peak at 22 to 25
and
man so 25 flip it at like 30. yeah so
then a man's hit in prime time at 28 to
like 36
and then the woman on the decline so
then what happens which was luke says is
if you're a 30 year old guy at the top
of the food chain you're going to be
like
why am i going to date a 30 year old who
was dating 30 years when she was 19
all through that when i can be i'm 30
years old i'm on top of the food chain
now like what are you gonna do
and then women get mad because they're
like well i have a career this and that
and then and that goes to the survey
earlier it's like one one thing that
really
surprises women in a way that's
unpleasant for them
is most men don't care what your career
is you know
i hate to be the bearer of bad news but
you can say i'm a middle level executive
at
the whatever thing and if a guy's got
his own thing going on he's like well
that's nice i'm happy for you
congratulations for your success but i
don't know dude i'm trying to like take
a trip
you want to like get on a plane or you
got to call in sick at work or you got
to get vacation time or whatever
yeah that's so that's actually something
i experienced i was i was in a
relationship with a
fairly uh prominent media individual
and it was just like you're doing your
thing that's really cool
then we're both doing our thing and so
there was no real opportunity to
actually spend time together
it's like if you've got your career and
your career is the most important thing
i got to be honest
all we really did was like sleep in the
same bed like
night comes and it's like how was your
day that's great and then we didn't
really do anything together
there was no shared mission right and
and it can't be that way
and like i'm i'm like what you said
earlier is if you're if you're like 19
years old
and you get to like have fun that's your
life man you know yeah men or women can
do whatever they want to do
the question was how mathematically that
sets us out so then you have men kind of
check out
and then men are kind of i don't know
man they're kind of lame and then
i know all these you know because when
you become a little bit more prominent
young women will kind of start to talk
to you a little bit more
and a lot of attractive women be like oh
man no guys hit on me and i'm like look
man i don't know what you're trying to
do here but i'm not the guy who's gonna
compliment you
and then i found out no no they weren't
fishing for compliments men don't
actually make a move
so i would be at places and it's like
junior high you know i'm 43 it's like
junior high all over again
so there'll be four girls over here
women or you know whatever young women
over here
four guys over here they're kind of like
looking and the guys don't make moves
anymore either
they're on their app they're like can i
swipe they're like i don't know make a
move or whatever whereas when you were
you know my you know when you were in
college your age or my age
you had to go make a move dude that's
the crazy thing i was thinking about
that when i was you know
like 18 19 20 we every weekend we would
be at some random house party
and it was literally just dudes walking
around hey what's up to women and
talking to them
and then they'd feel it out and then
they'd either leave or that was it like
congratulations you met someone now
you're gonna go hang out or do something
now it's all like pre-screened on an app
you know bumble the
the woman who invented bumble but
becomes a billionaire where only the
women can make the opening move
like these apps have have i'm you know
what i'm not going to say this i don't
know what the long-term effects of this
are going to be so i'm not here to make
like a harsh criticism
of the dating scene or the choices of
men and women just pointing out the
differences that i've experienced
and what i think might be affecting men
and women at certain ages well
i mean the we see the results and i'm
happy to make a prediction
the results are if you're like a guy at
the top of the food chain
you're king kong again you're an
aristocracy you have all the cards on
the table
we've returned to an aristocracy where
you can live as a man a life that you
couldn't have lived unless you were like
royalty
i was talking to a friend about this i
was like i think like a lot of this
feminist liberation stuff and apps have
been the greatest thing
for like douchey alpha guys oh for sure
without question
because now it's like they're they're
going on apps and they're
swiping around literally every woman
then they're getting then
they wait for the woman message them
back and they just like i love these
memes where like one guy will message 50
women the same thing and go
oh man that's that you all saw that oops
thinking it was going to be like a blind
carbon copy or something
yeah so what i what i've noticed from a
lot of this there's a lot of regular
dudes
clueless and cut out and there's a lot
of guys that are
prominent successful wealthy who are
just
owning the game and they're doing it
unabashedly because
they're leaning into the sexual
revolution too which is okay
their guys are just like okay i just
don't do monogamy dude
you know you got a problem with that
fine with me whatever this is kind of
the way it's going to be and everything
is free nobody's being compelled to do
anything
and so then the competition becomes less
because more and more people check out
it creates this like vicious cycle
so then you do that the winner of all
this stuff are the the top one
one to ten percent of men are the people
who won
from the dating apps and that and
okcupid showed that
okay cube but they they had all this
great you could never do this now it
shows how far cancelled culture is they
deleted one on ugliness
yep like if you're an ugly guy you're
doomed and they deleted it because they
were like
well then they did one too where when
you call somebody a douchebag
those people the guy with the shirt off
in front of the corvette actually gets
yes hit up more by the women so if
you're like so anyway
they said they said although many women
will stay in their profiles
if you're not wearing your shirt don't
bother they actually tend to respond
more to men who are not wearing shirts
right so all the empirical data show
that if you're the
douchebag guy take your shirt off
wax your car show pictures of you by the
eiffel tower
you're gonna actually get head up and if
you're the respectable guy i'm very nice
you know i
i read all the feminists late you're not
going to get anything but that's of
course why they had to delete it because
the empirical data was in direct
conflict with the narrative
there was there was one they had
specifically about attractiveness and
what they found is
men will message women similar to their
own level of attractiveness
so it's a bell curve but women
overwhelmingly overvalue their
attractiveness and only try going for
the best of the best guys
so it's something like what is it like
20 of the guys get 90
of the messages right something like
that and it's all the top tier best of
the best
chiseled six foot five you know models
and you think about like shirts off
tribalism in general you'd have a group
of women
and they'd all have one guy that they
would use for the
semen to have the children and that
that's how it went and now it's like
we're reverting back to that almost
it's unfortunate and that's what that's
evolving to a new version of it yeah
we're devolving and that that's
evolving or devolving i don't know well
i i'm kind of either i think it's a
change or whatever well
that's where i'm an institutionalist so
you know that's why i can represent john
roberts and
maybe jordan peterson's point of view
where he got trouble with enforced
monogamy because people
can't have an adult conversation but if
you don't if you don't want to be like
the middle east
where one guy has all five women
and now four guys have nothing to do but
blow things up or get angry get
radicalized
the idea that if we want to live in a
socially cohesive
stable culture i want people paired up i
want
people having kids at an early age i
want them thinking about the next
generation
i like i said i'm a cocky
institutionalist i like
social stability and in social order and
i think you know
probably less than jordan peterson does
but that's where jordan peterson got in
trouble
it's called enforced monogamy right and
what happened was you had i think some
feminist writers
thought what he was saying was you would
take women and force them to be with
with men
and what he was saying was that just
social and yeah like cultural like hey
you should get married you should think
about having a family here's how it
changed
when you how i'm 43 i'm probably the
oldest in the room right
yeah the other one okay yeah so enforced
monogamy would just be when you were
like my age if you cheated on your
girlfriend you were like a scumbag
you know even your guy friends you're
not getting like high fives unless the
other guy was kind of like a scumbag
right you're just like jesus dude like
your girlfriend's nice what are you
doing
that's enforced monogamy it isn't that
you have to do it but there's just a
cultural norm
well another thing we have to understand
here people not mating people not having
partners leads to social decay
leads to crime leads to violence leads
to radicalization
leads to you know again i saw one of the
stats i forgot the exact kind of
parameters of it but it was
people who don't get laid usually tend
to be blowing themselves up or attacking
people or to be some of the most
creative i mean that's
that's a that's a problem man no one no
one deserves
to get laid like no no woman owes any
guy anything like that
so i don't know how you solve for that
i'm assuming the data is probably true
i've heard similar things but
i don't know what are you supposed to do
in that regard well nothing as a society
i mean that's the whole point is that
you're
you're not saying that it you should
change it or that you can change it
it is what it is to quote you know
donald trump which got him all in
trouble is
i think it's a bad situation societally
but what am i going to do
that is what it is but also let's let's
make the point here that a lot of
institutional establishment mainstream
media
hollywood powers promote this larger
message of promiscuity of not having
partners of not having
families there was even advertisements
by the nih in the united kingdom telling
people
do you want to have your video games or
do you want to have a baby do you want
to have your high heels or do you want
to have a baby as if having a baby is
something bad and taking away from you
having fun playing video games
are you wearing high heels or doing
whatever you want to do but it's almost
it's almost like
they just want you to be a kid they
don't want you to grow up you know did
you post that meme earlier the high
heels and lipstick okay
because i saw that and the weird thing
just is like a married guy is
the uh it's actually sex gets better
when you're with the person longer
because you know what like boundaries
are and
you know things aren't going to go too
far and everybody kind of like knows
what's going on
so i saw that i was like actually these
women don't know that in
like a committed relationship they're
going to have more intimacy they're
actually have a better time
so the idea that like you're going to
have a kid and you're never going to
wear a lipstick
and lingerie and high heels is probably
the opposite you're more likely to do
you know forgot your weight
i grew up with tv telling me marriage
was bad and having a family was awful
i mean i i you know what show i really
could never i hated was made with
children yeah
and the reason i hated it was not
because he was you know he it was
because he was a loser
it was because he always lost the only
the only episode i remember where
al bundy actually won was when he
punched a guy in the face
and then they joked that he sued him and
won for hurting his fist on his face
and it was because like the show was
making a point that the system was
broken
but like i watched this show you know
when i when it would come out i was i
was young
and he was always just miserable he
hated his kids he hated his wife they
hated everything and i was like what is
this it's
awful we weren't allowed to watch it our
parents weren't there
look at the way a family is
characterized in in mainstream media
television and sitcoms and movies look
at the way that the father is portrayed
look at his characters look at what he
stands for look at how he acts he's a
dumb dopey
fat dope that doesn't give a damn about
anything and is absolutely miserable so
so seeing that representation plays on
the subconscious of so many young
americans of so many young children
and it's the complete utter opposite of
what's happening in china
china huge population crisis because of
their one child policy
they're literally building databases of
fertile women
inside of beijing with millions of
people yes china is building
databases of how fertile women are in
beijing
uh and that's and we only know about
that because that was leaked there's
other stuff that they're doing i mean
they're creating machines that suck out
your
uh life at the male energy uh
family-friendly show here i'm trying to
watch my word here but you saw
i don't know if you guys seen this but
the chinese machine reproductive matter
yes
yes they're literally building machines
that build your re
that suck out your reproductive matter
they're they're trying to make males
more masculine they're not alone
they're not allowing immigration uh
they're a very nationalistic
country uh lydia looks scared they're
horrified
but that's happening that's the reality
of the world that we're facing and if
you compare what
if you compare what china's doing to
what the west is doing
it's a completely different approach and
one of them is going to be successful
another one is not
we got to go to super chats because we
went a little long but it's okay make
sure you go to
timcast.com become a member if you
haven't already because we've got a ton
of uh we got three
full bonus episodes up just in the past
week or so it's fantastic we got sydney
watson
we got phoenix ammunition these are the
guys who said no biden voters allowed
you can't buy the ammo
and they go and we got james o'keefe as
well so we'll have a bonus segment up
later
and if you haven't already smash the
like button subscribe to the
notification bell let's read some super
chats
all right let's see we got grayson says
saw today on uk channel 4 news an
interview with enrique tario
was aired about january 6. what i found
interesting though is they clearly used
a filter to make him look white to trick
brits who know nothing about proud boys
is that true did you guys hear that i
i didn't i wouldn't be surprised yeah i
wouldn't be surprised either
eric gresham says look into china's
100-year plan world domination type
stuff yes
i was actually working on a story when i
was at vice we talked about this quite a
bit
never really came to fruition though
chris clark says there was a vault
surrounded by a town
a bunch of waiters snuck into the vault
and said they were smart enough to be
the overseer took it over
and took all the weapons they control
the vault now and the town
the vault was was facebook was is that a
fallout reference
i'm not entirely sure payne cabal says
welcome to the not playing magic club
tim i figured mtg was pay to win after
two games
the week it came out yup yup you know
rag on magic the gathering again
martin edgar says tim can you clarify if
crowder made reference to the votes from
the fictitious
uh votes refer specific party or
candidate i don't believe so
because uh so here's how it works
crowder did this and
voter integrity project did this you can
get access to publicly available
available voter information people who
voted
you cannot see who they voted for so
what happens is they pull up this
information
get a list of addresses and then my
understanding i could be wrong i think
crowder
loaded up these addresses into a a
database checking whether
or not you can deliver packages to them
and found a bunch that said you can't
deliver packages to them
then went investigated and found a bunch
of parking lots and you know
there you go then he tweeted about it
and he got temporarily suspended
you know we'll see william martin says
hey tim are you going to upload the
podcast from last friday in full to
youtube i missed that one
it won't be on youtube because we can't
re-upload like because it was live so
they go live and they get published
the clips are up but we will have it on
timcast.com in a free area
that i think we have ready to go
hopefully i just got to get it figured
out
we do have uh the website's getting
totally redone we're just getting
started it's only been about a month so
uh
thank you everybody who signed up mark
skog says thanks for having
mike on he's a good guy mark puts up
barrier from the haters
but seriously dr shiva won a case
against massachusetts and got them
restrained from colluding with twitter
did you hear about that is that no i
haven't heard about this yeah i don't
know about that matthew
loucher says crowder caught a very
damning sound bite of biden yesterday
and shows actual proof of fraud today
it's not actual proof crowder even said
that he said
it was evidence of fake voter addresses
i
well actually i could be wrong maybe he
did say fraud i don't think so i think
he was very very specific and precise
for a reason when you're trying to prove
something definitively you have to make
sure you're choosing the right words
which is why
i don't even think i'm pretty sure matt
brainard has never said fraud either he
said potentially illegal ballots
that's a very important distinction
because you want the courts to take it
and like you were saying about
legitimacy if you come in and say these
wild conspiracies they're going to throw
you out back i don't want to do i don't
want to be involved in this
if you're very well it's just potential
maybe you could take a look they might
come out and say oh i agree
you know all right let's see arcadian
twilight says mike what is your opinion
of
ricketta law i'm not sure what that is
uh i think he's referring to the
youtuber oh i don't know
well there you go simple answer
let's see let's uh move a little bit uh
tony boy says
what good is a referee if the opposing
side and the opposing fans ignore the
ruling
scotus needs to enforce the rulings and
laws that have been passed
i think you you mentioned they have no
ability to enforce exactly exactly
right so who is so so what who who's
supposed to enforce this
well technically uh core or is
enforceable by us
marshals it would be enforceable as
civil contempt which would
uh you know get federal federal forces
so the executive branch or the
government would be the enforcement
mechanism
which requires a soft power neither
power of
a person or sword is the way they put it
phillip keddick says tim they aren't
cages anymore they're shelters
that's right sorta jumple
jump hey says tim check out the
orville's majority rule episode
the crew discovers a planet where
society is governed by up and down votes
after enough down votes you get a brain
wipe scary look at our future yeah i saw
that one that's what i love about the
orville you guys have you have you seen
it seth macfarlane's show
is that they're they're carrying on a
bit of what the next generation did from
star trek
philosophical it's almost like black
mirror in a sense where they find these
different worlds
and they kind of ask the question of
like what would the society be like if
we did these kinds of things
so it's you know it's interesting stuff
good fun good show good for the family
big e says the left gets mad when you
separate children from strangers they
don't know what a surprise
you know lanius shrike says if fauci
just said spend
spend more time in the sun everyone
would benefit he did say that
dr fauci did tell everybody to get more
sunlight vitamin d
is because it's a it's good for you and
you need it so uh gotta be fair gotta be
fair
gizmo 79 says we have universal health
care if an adult or child breaks their
arm or has dehydration from the flu they
can go to the er and they cannot be
refused care but they can be bankrupt
medic come on bro
yeah they get bankrupted and then they
garnish your wages you get your credit
destroyed you can't rent you can't buy
property
you know what's really crazy about the
system you could be paying two grand a
month in new york for rent and a bank
will tell you
yeah but we're not gonna give you a
thousand dollar a month mortgage because
we don't think you you know right
you have the credit you're not credit
worthy yeah like we don't trust you it's
like dude i gotta pay rent either way
and i'm paying twice as much
let me buy the house i think that's dumb
all right tp says good good initials by
the way hey i know this is super off
topic but i was wondering if you know
about or could raise awareness of bill
c-21 in canada gun owners losing their
rights if this bill passes
i don't know a lot about does anybody
know about that one no no everyone's
shaking their heads sorry guys
i guess we're we're not the oracle
tonight like we usually are
rogue says tim just lightly disparaged
anime cat girls and i took that
personally
jk didn't wasn't like elon musk posting
anime can't grow something weirdo
matt l says antifa at least does
something for their side
that's true yep that's true so you have
antifa on the left
actually going out throwing temper
tantrums making demands
and they're getting what they want right
kind of i i think i
i still maybe i'm delusional but i think
they've done way more harm than good
oh totally yeah i think they've allowed
the the more everything now is looks bad
now because it's tied to antifa so i
think they've done a lot more harm than
good
yeah nick sweeney says what happened to
the i am a gorilla love yourself shirt
i was holding out for that one also if
you guys ever do a pop culture night you
should have on the guys from clown you
should have the guys on from clownfishtv
um i mean we've had uh uh jeremy from
the quartering so we'll have him around
he's cool dude
the i'm a girl love yourself shirt is
just in the works i guess we have like
one graphic designer who you know works
on merch for the show
and then i had to do the hour pillow so
like we have a
a silly version from teespring where
it's the revolution fist holding a
pillow
and the my is crossed out so it says our
not my but we actually do have just over
there behind the end we've got the uh
the official uh our pillow oh you can
see it there it is yeah look at that
there it is that's the burlap sack full
of packing peanuts and we used paper
clips to keep it shut
fancy and uh i i am not joking i fully
intend to buy a commercial on fox news
and there has been movements there have
been movements made in that direction
i have uh i've um contacted
the appropriate agencies they said so
long as it's a real commercial they
don't care if i want to spend the money
then it's fine
and we're working on putting the
commercial together i think it'll be a
whole lot of fun and i think it'll be
good for everybody good for everybody
matt l says what's luke's thought on
bobby fischer and his calls
i'm not aware of that situation but uh
let me know of that situation by
tweeting at me i'll be facing the test
player that's who i thought yeah
i don't know what's up with these super
chats they're very descriptive yes i
love it
kpoc says tim is right i watch my
favorite youtube channels on my tv
i usually don't need to chime in and i
don't want to engage with the haters in
chat
yeah yep that's uh that's the gist of it
i think a lot of people
i noticed i noticed that too as i my
engagement got really low
and then i when i released hoaxed a year
ago i was like oh man i wonder if the
film's gonna flop
and it actually did way better than i
even thought my projections were so
it's like not even a silent majority
anymore it's like a silent
99 of people who just like your stuff
and support it when it matters and don't
say anything
good or bad yeah track media only says
time claimed a conspiracy occurred
how many other things faked to help win
does it does it take to show
another or part of the same so much fear
of a word that when one could be true it
is dismissed
they win by that fear proof of proof
allah time
you know can i answer that real quick
which is the if you go back to the
the jfk election with richard nixon none
of this stuff
this is again that's the first time
voter right there who doesn't realize if
you've read history or if you looked at
bush versus gore
uh this is always gonna happen it's just
shenanigans but the idea that it's
r-i-g-g-e-d puts too much weight on it
you have two people on either side
there's going to be shenanigans
everywhere you look at
and and that's the election every
election even bill barr said
there was fraud just not that they've
seen that could have any serious impact
but it's true i mean it was it was
paxton was in texas i think that when we
got arrested and charged
then there was even a video that was put
out by think some some progressives
where was a woman
who claimed to have voted for trump
twice so you always you always have
people
you know ballot harvesting was a and
that's what frustrates me i guess is
that uh
somebody kind of plugged into how it
really works is ballot harvesting was
the
was what did it but ballot harvesting
you know the james the key videos for
example bala harvesting was being way
overdone
but they were still actually real
ballots now now was it
a a nurse filling out the balance of
alzheimer's patients i would like to
know but guess what we can't know
because everybody's so fixated on that
one word and you have to have that one
word as the grand meta narrative for
what happened whereas instead you could
say like well i don't know did this
happen let's look into that well people
people were easily distracted by the
sensational right and that's what my
problem was i was like dude stop
talking about the fringe weirdo stuff
and just talk about the supreme court
case on
the legitimacy of you know or the the
the electors clause
that that's that's your key right there
the elector's clause but instead what
happens is they're
you know people scream the most crazy
conspiracy about server attacks and
shootouts
and people prefer the the you know the
crazy shocking conspiracy narrative
because it's fun
i guess life is boring i think you might
have a stink bug on your microphone
stand no not on you not on you on the
stand just so you know
it's fine okay in case chad starts going
crazy about it yeah i thought it had a
mike pence moment there was a
fly brown bear says tim
it's uh referencing me saying it's a
standalone complex in time magazine
saying it is not a standalone complex
this is the funny thing
so i have an update on that uh uh
pointer institute calling me out or
lying about me
so uh photos unfamiliar pointer and
astute uh pointer institute essentially
runs the organization that
determines who is allowed to be a fact
checker on facebook they created a post
where they said twitter's
fact-checking system has got problems
why because
tim poole made a post which said the
election was rigged that's actually not
true
the post literally says time magazine
claimed the election
a cabal of elites rigged the election
i'm sorry they didn't say it was rigged
as it was fortified
quite literally the post says it wasn't
rigged well they claimed i
posted the opposite which is just
factually not correct then they
complained
that twitter's users noted correctly
on my post it was not misleading because
i was just being snarky and referencing
a time magazine article
so another outlet recently did a update
made a correction and i'm eternally
grateful for the correction it was the
right thing to do
and it flipped the article which now
they wrote the same thing pointer did
but with this correction
it inverted the narrative now they're
writing about how pointer
misframed my tweet which was accurate
and their post was wrong
and so it's weirdly criticizing
birdwatch while recognizing
they were correct and it worked the
funny thing is
i sent this to another journalist at one
of these prominent acting
fact-checking organizations here's
here's the update and there's a funny
there's a funny bit of
uh real uh a realization in this
if i message one of these prominent
journalists and say hey here's my tweet
that's not true
they'll say screw off but when i showed
him a screenshot that said correction
tim's actual tweet referenced time
magazine he did not say this himself
they went oh
[Music]
you see how that works simply having it
in text
from someone from other journalists
they'll blindly believe it without facts
okay but i'll teach you the life hack so
the life hack is they know that their
twitter dms aren't discoverable in a
lawsuit
so what i do is i always find out who
their lawyers were on their pre i go i
go way out of my way to do this stuff
so you want to pay per trail them so
anytime they do that rather than message
the reporter
message general counsel of the media
holding company that owns it
include the lawyer and the cc then
include the editor-in-chief because then
what will happen is if something like
covington happens and people sue
that's why cnn sell the lawsuit they'll
go and be like oh look you you know you
did this to everybody you've done it 100
times so
i don't even bother with twitter dms i
go right to hr i go right to the general
console oh no i i didn't dm anybody
okay i'm sorry i'm sorry the dm was to a
journalist as
i wasn't asking the journalist for a
correction i was like hey and update it
for the record
the correction i got because i literally
sent an email in much the way you
described right okay gotcha i was very
polite and i said
you know i appreciate your time i humbly
request that you simply make the
correction
thank you very much when you're using
snark in like
tweets how does it work because if i was
like lukowski murdered some
murdered random pers i'll pick a person
oh no he didn't actually murder him he
just said he didn't like him
right like would i be liable for saying
that luke murdered someone okay so quick
so their quick uh defamation law of that
would be is
they look at two things in addition to
tone they look at the forum
so it's almost impossible to defame
someone on twitter it has to be like
really specific
and it can't just be colorful language
it would have to be something like
ruth uh it'd have to be something like
luke's friend
told me that he tried to stab his friend
and that gives it a certain likened
issue of credibility but
that's why when the elon musk remember
he called that guy pedo guy
yeah people were surprised that that
even went to trial because it's like i
mean he's on twitter and he called
someone a pedo
that's kind of like what happens on
twitter so j but the forum changes but
if it's in the new york times
then that's considered a more serious
forum and they have to be
more careful but but but as a general
rule you never want a
statement of fact versus opinion so i
you know you're you're a terrible person
it's like a moral judgment
but if you accuse someone of a very
specific crime
with enough detail that has an indicia
that it would be a truthful thing that
you knew
about that's when you get jammed there's
also really really clever tactics
that they use they love doing this thing
where they'll name somebody
and then add like a comma and then some
descriptor that makes no sense
so like uh mike cernovich you once went
to
an ice cream shop and he dropped his
vanilla ice cream on the floor and a
little kid slipped and fell and busted
his skull open
what they'll do is mike cernovich comma
who once took actions which resulted in
busting open a child's skull comma
was seen at the park today and that's
the truth it's a statement of fact and
they're allowed to say it
yeah that's that's why they also play
the association game
so so and so kama who's associated with
kama
who's associated with white nationalism
or whatever you want to insert that's
what they do it's a very dirty game
i call it like the parenthetical of
death but that's also too why the media
has lost its soft power i was talking to
will about this i think it was talking
about
it was will i was talking about this so
i'll ask your opinion if someone defames
you
and it's a it's an overt false statement
in fact they won't correct
what if you just defamed them to a more
extreme degree with a very serious
statement effect
to force discovery well yeah you you
just force um
so that's a tactic yeah that would be
the tactic which is let's just
everybody go under oath because i've had
people because fortunately i've never
defamed anyone
they're you know because the things they
say that i've defamed people on like the
pi
g-a-t-e thing i'm like well why was i
never issued a retraction because i've
actually been defamed in terms of how
they described my role
in a certain thing that happened on the
internet and i won't say the words to
get you flagged or whatever
but i that that's the idea the idea is
if somebody says temple is blank
you could just say well you know what i
don't know if i can sue you for this but
i'll just say something about you
now you go ahead and sue me tough guy
and i'll go under oath and then i'll get
all your documents and i'm glad to go
under oath with you yeah so i was
talking about this because the thing is
when it comes to discovery
there's a certain chain of
communications that will be allowed if
someone defames you through the pro
through an editorial process
there's a lot of discovery there but if
you just come out with no editorial
process
and make your statement you know on your
end you've got nothing to lose in a
discovery
whereas they might actually have
something more serious yeah i've had
people
you know threaten me all the time that's
one reason california has what's called
the anti-slap law which is
uh if they sue you and you win they have
to pay your legal fees where in other
states they don't have to
because i i'm like look man i s what i
say what i say what i believe
and if i believe so because you've
correct i think one time the first time
we talked with berkeley
you had been like oh yeah you said this
thing about black lives matter and it
was like actually not true and then i
told you it wasn't true and you're like
okay am i bad and i corrected it
you know because what i say i believe to
be true and if if you tell me no
actually it's not true and here's why
it's not true
then of course i'm going to delete it
and like change it yeah that's probably
why in a way
that the media is so like jarring to me
because if you're just like a human
being
i've even deleted things that were true
that were harming a person's like google
results
i i tweeted about aoc's timeline when
she was lying about what happened at the
capitol and she lied
yep she did and i had a huff post
journalist uh dm me saying you're wrong
you're spreading this information
and so i looked into it and was like i
better take this down you know because
like that's you know i i think he's
right
and after doing a deep investigation i
followed up saying
here's the real facts and he was like oh
oh yeah
i was wrong long story short aoc claimed
that she thought
they got in a full hour before anyone
had actually stormed any part of any
building
so you had a bunch of trump supporters
outside yelling rebel and then she was
claiming that they broke into like that
that made no sense her timeline was way
off
but i digress i try to well but if we're
digressing i try not to talk about her
too much but
did you see the fact check where people
were quoting her saying that
protest isn't supposed to be comfortable
and you're supposed and then she tried
to get a fact checker
to say well aoc actually never said that
even though she said it
yeah yeah and some of the fact checkers
that go along with that oh she meant
something completely different
let's uh let's read this here this big
old super chat from jmac he says
i work from home and have been the
primary stay-at-home parent since i left
the military
parenting is all about teamwork and
parents should figure out what works for
them
it also helps to have a good scale of
masculine and feminine traits for your
kids to pick up on
even in gay couples interesting
occupy says luke you mentioned emotional
manipulation via media repetition
conditioning
so true much of this past year has been
direct foreign media influence namely
china
let's not forget how this all started
this time last year it's also pretty
scary the influence that china has on
not just entertainment but the news
business and how many news executives
are afraid
to even uh you know voice their concerns
about anything china's doing
well it's concentration media ownership
that's what's funny is how the right and
the left have switched
where everybody it was like a left-wing
talking point at least when i was in
college you'd buy like ad busters
and the idea was that six media
conglomerates ordered everything and
so if you're nbc news are you gonna say
anything that's gonna put nbc universal
into apparel with china are you going to
disrupt the next disneyland
if you're you know downstream at abc and
the answer is like of course not
but we're all supposed to pretend so
that's where the influence that two
arises
all right we got stankly balls says tim
honestly how are the apple legend
mountains
how would you compare to the rockies
besides prices and height
it's funny how dude covered the new
economic powerhouses are in florida and
texas and new york and ca are broke
floor and texas and new york and sea are
broke
uh the appalachian mountains are green
and beautiful well not right now it's
mostly white with snow yeah the rockies
are just rocks yep it's rocks
it's it's not fun i've driven through
them many times uh i mean
it's beautiful to look at rocks you know
used to go go to the rockies you know
look at all that stuff it's fun but when
you're uh when you're on the east coast
a lot of rain a lot of trees a lot of
animals
a lot of yeah yeah and if you get up
north you get black flies i guess is
what they're called
that's i was looking at maine and people
are like don't do it because you'll get
bit in the summer it's really awful
yeah because you want to be by the water
it's all idyllic and then you realize
you're getting attacked by it
yeah you're getting attacked by other
forms of life
casey finnegan says the canadian
government had a vote on whether to
designate the ccp
as committing genocide against the
uyghurs justin trudeau and his whole
cabinet abstained from voting what is
that true
it's true but i don't know if i don't
know there's a reason that they had to
abstain though
because it was i think it was the
unanimous vote so
that i think that's something like a
parliamentary procedure that i have to
look into before i had an opinion
yeah yeah trudeau's comments on china
are very eye-opening
barry kitchen says 12 years army ranger
vet here started watching you roughly
five months ago seeing you on rogan well
done just wanted to say much respect to
you great really appreciate it thank you
gizmo 79 says very rarely does a
hospital turn er bills to creditors
most are written off of their taxes
interesting
i i have heard that they sell
they sell it to debt collectors on
pennies on the dollar yeah and the debt
collectors go after people and then
maybe the debt collectors
because you're only buying it pennies on
the dollar let people go but there's
absolutely medical bankruptcies
yeah a lot of this happens one of the
leading causes of bankruptcy is medical
bankruptcy come on people come at me
with the facts
yeah man that's you know i was thinking
about
how you do you remember when occupy wall
street uh did that thing where they
bought up all that medical debt
yep that was cool and now it's very
simple they just said give us some
donations and then
it's like for every dollar it's like a
hundred dollars of debt wiped clean
like i like that idea i don't know if
it's a long-term solution but at least
it can provide some relief to some
people who are suffering you know yeah
and it's a better way using money
than you know anything else so yeah
that's why we look at practical
solutions because
the only reason that i would be
quote-unquote against universal
healthcare is because
you still have the principal agency
issue where i don't believe you can
justly order a doctor to perform
services
at certain wages and who pays for it so
the weeds are complex
the one thing we have to bring up is
like are we gonna be paying for people
who are unhealthy
you know who are who are eating poorly
not exercising laying around getting
sick and then it's gonna be a burden for
literally everybody it's a challenge
because we don't want people to die but
people gotta have some responsibilities
you know yeah they're kids i mean
there's a lot like my solution would be
kind of like i call it cancer and kids
so like if you have a sick kid man i
don't care if you're like a bad parent
the kid it's not the kid's fault
and then if you have some kind of
unforeseen cancer or something like that
then
you know there'd obviously be gradations
but if you you know if you eat yourself
into a
diabetic coma i don't know man we're a
different situation
all right so wp says mike i listened to
gorilla mindset on a solo road trip in
2019 it was eye-opening
i was able to get my hands on danger and
play what's the true story was it really
banned i didn't find the defensive
no the book wasn't banned the books have
a certain life cycle to them
and you know when a book stops selling i
just usually pull it
because then you can re-release it and
there's more height behind it so
yeah yeah so the way because i almost
pulled a gorilla mindset but then it got
enrolled in this like
kendall great on kindle program so i
didn't so just from a marketing
perspective is like guerrilla mindset
lived on its life cycle and it did like
really well
and if i pull it for like a year or two
and then i re-release it
it's gonna do way more in a month than
it would have done
in two years yeah and then some so you
always want to pull things and
re-release it
even though they're digital goods and
that's counter-intuitive palani casey
says i'm a full-time
full-time er nurse with a family of four
and i'm the sole financial provider
i did nursing school as a single mom i
want to be a homemaker
feminism made me believe homemaking was
less say no to toxic masculinity
wait what was that again they didn't
they she likes being a homemaker
she wants to be a homemaker but feminism
made her believe
homemaking was less oh yeah absolutely i
mean like i said i deal with that just
my own personal life where
shauna's like was insecure about being a
stay-at-home mom so i call myself a
stay-at-home dad actually
so if you watch my streams i'm like oh
yeah i'm just a stay-at-home dad
to try to get away from that stigma i we
were talking about this
months and months ago and i referenced
uh family guy because there's an episode
about this where
lois griffin you know encounters some
businesswoman
who looks down on her because she's a
homemaker i i use pop culture references
because surprise surprise
how many people watch family guy and
watch his movies and understand what
these references are and
find it relatable but this is what like
the left loves to do they like to use
that as some sort of like
they have this like pseudo-intellectual
academic nature to the way they
communicate as if it's like better than
you
and by all means go for it i look at how
trump was able to
pull off one of the greatest media
manipulations i've ever seen
ordering that you know dry age steak
with ketchup well done
right and then the media mocked and
insulted him
and it was like telling middle america
like they were mocking and insulting you
as well
so i'm like listen i'm here to talk to
regular people who watch regular tv
shows
who are like yeah oh i get that i've
seen that if you want to come out and
act high and mighty and academic like
you're smarter than everybody
you just isolate yourself so by all
means go ahead and do it
yeah i just don't watch anything so but
luckily i watched a lot of tv when i was
younger so i get the family guy
references the married children kind of
stuff oh married with children was the
worst
you know to really hate it was ed and
eddie you guys ever see that show
it's a kid is a cartoon on cartoon
network i remember when i was a kid i
was like it's a show about three kids
who are losers just absolute losers
who always fail and everyone hates them
and i was like what an awful show
just like what's with this miserable
these miserable cartoons where people
are just users
well and again that's the programming
that's why that's why my views on
representation minorities would probably
be
shocking to people because there's more
left wing which representation does
matter but it works like both ways too
you shouldn't represent men as schlubby
guys get hen packed by a wife
because that's sending a bad message
about family too so yeah but
representation doesn't matter at least
beaves and butthead were
content a very important message from
dingus malingas says hi tim i'm about
your age and when i was in high school
the messaging was that having a baby
would ruin your life
in order to prevent teen pregnancies
maybe that sentiment carried into
adulthood
i think it absolutely did good it didn't
maybe it didn't to me i didn't have
my first kid was 38 and i'm like man i
should have started earlier
man why did it take cuz i i really
thought like you have a kid who ruined
your life like
why would i give up my freedom because
that's the idea is you're giving up your
freedom but you're getting love and
you're giving love and you're opening up
your heart
and your reality is something different
but yeah i fell for that science yeah
it's gonna
i'll tell you this you know it's gonna
be it's gonna be crazy is what like 50
years
when you've got a bunch of these
millennials who are
get getting older you know developing
dementia
and other you know cognitive cognitive
decline and they've got nobody
they're they're what are you gonna do
like right right now it's really easy
for a lot of these
uh you know single millennials to just
hang out with their buddies
but when you are all entering the you
know the the downward you know the back
end of the bell curve for your for your
life
you need someone to take care of you i
mean i think about this a lot because i
don't have kids i'm 41
i don't really want kids or plan on it
and i think
like socrates didn't have kids but he
had the tribe
and they supported him and he had like
friends and like even the young he had
the kids of the
the greco kids would follow him around
the 12 year olds and he would tell them
the truth
listen they're all gonna maybe all of
these 80 year old millennials will vote
for government assistance well you'll
you'll you'll
you'll have good home care um you know
you'll have enough money
money saved up by then that you have
good and who knows you might be 50
that's the thing
that's where you know talking about the
gender stuff earlier that's where the
game is
rigged in favor of men is if you're 50
and you're like all right i'm going to
marry him like a 30 year old and i'm
going to have
three kids 18 year old you know well you
know which you know i try to keep a
little family friendly
totally legal and socially acceptable
for 58 year old
socially exciting it's not socially
acceptable it is no it isn't
there's still a stigma there there's no
it's not kind of crazy but it is
there's memes every single day mocking
leonardo dicaprio for constantly dating
the same woman and dumping them at the
same age it's not socially acceptable
i'm not judging
i'm just saying that if you're 50 i
doubt you're going to want to have
children with an 18 year old i think you
would lose
well so this is actually part of
okcupid's data they found that
i'm not going to get into the really
creepy findings they published because
it was
nightmarishly disgusting but what they
said was that when it comes to
any man of any age the reason why they
choose 22
is not because it's the ideal age it's
the ideal combination of maturity
and and youthful like vigor so
it's actually a pretty disgusting study
that okay okay cupid put out because the
age
actually goes a bit further down a
little too low yeah creepy
but when they were like when they would
ask a guy would you date an 18 year old
they'd be like oh
no way because it's like there's a big
difference between an 18 year old and a
22 year old
definitely just the human brain changes
so much
i mean you're totally mature to 23 they
say is when you're like your body's
fully mature well
and women mature a little bit quicker
than men too so a 22 year old woman on
average is going to be
or girl whatever you call them it's
going to be more mature than like a 20
year old guy
for sure too so 25 you're like yeah that
but if you're um yeah if you're 15 18
even 10 years which is the gap between
me and shauna's
about about as much as i could do yeah
well with that being said
i think uh we will have you all smash
that like button go to timcast.com
because in about an hour or so we'll
have
the bigger segment on probably one of
the most important and pressing issues
that has happened in the past
couple of years i don't want to get too
much into it because youtube is insane
but
cernovich was uh one of the legal uh
parties to
blowing the lid on the whole epstein
case and that's correct right like
that's it yeah yeah the law degree came
in handy
you know a lot of a lot of things that
that you know like i could explain the
institutional
mindset of john roberts thing yeah we'll
get into all that yeah
we're going to get to all this in a
bonus segment where we're going to get
pretty serious and probably a lot of
like you know a family unfriendly things
to say so
go to timgast.com become a member that
should be up hopefully in about an hour
or so
make sure you smash that like button you
can follow me on all social media at
tim cast you can check out my other
youtube channels youtube.comcast and
youtube.comcast
this show is live monday friday at 8pm
so make sure you like share subscribe
tell all your friends about it mike is
there anything you wanted to mention
well you know
by gorilla mindset it's actually a great
mindset book and i want to have to pull
it some kind of marketing gimmick and
re-release it
you know yeah and they have they have a
gorilla here this is very important
everybody it's a great looking girl and
we should bundle the i am a gorilla
t-shirt
well no but if you look at the magazine
we're proud of the book cover shawna
designed it so you're actually
supporting
stay-at-home moms you're supporting
women it's a very feminist thing
it's just a win all around there you go
you're a great marketer
i'm also tweeting up a storm on luke we
are change and i'm pretty close to
getting 700
000 youtube subscribers so go to
youtube.com
we are change if you're not subscribed
yet even if you are subscribed
check it out because a lot of people are
being unsubscribed we are change on
youtube i did a very uh informative
video about reproductive rates
testosterone levels and the deep
population that's happening
on my youtube channel today it's
definitely interesting go check it out
we are change youtube
oh hello i uh i was just checking out
mike's book
you can also follow me on eddie
crossland.net you can check out all my
social networks you can get there
through there hit me up on mines
and uh follow me on twitch.tv slash ian
crossland where i will be going live to
play some video games with adam kriegler
and more very excited very cool and i am
sour patch lids i push all the buttons
in the corner and add unnecessary
comments at intervals
um i am real sour patch lids on twitter
and mines and i am
uh oh no no i'm real sour patch lids on
instagram and
gab and then i'm sour pachelets on
twitter and mines
we will see you all over at timcast.com
for the much more serious exclusive
episode thanks for hanging out we'll see
you then
you